you say that you're useless to the world
if you're not competing and you need
enemies to drive you
why um I think most people who say they
don't have enemies they probably don't
want to tell others they have the enemy
or they don't want to disclose it
they're great poker players I don't know
a single person that doesn't have an
enemy uh everybody does we're we're very
good at
concealing our insecurities our emotions
our fears our wildest desires our uh uh
enemies or comments that rub us the
wrong way that wire us uh we are very
good actors incredible actors right now
if you have a long time of talking to
somebody and you kind of watch them
closely and the more they talk and then
eventually you're going to find some
leaks you're like o I just found one
right there boom I found one
contradiction right there boom I found
one and they like okay interesting we
all have a little bit of that but I do
think
that when you study the people that do
something very big I'm not talking about
small I'm talking really really big
we're talking about some interesting
people today you and I have somebody we
both respect a lot Robert Green his
books I'm sure you love his books I love
his books 33 Strategies of War I
couldn't put it down for two years
straight I listen to that book every day
in my car straight every day it was on
repeat for two years straight why though
because I innocent got into sales and I
had a good time in sales and business
after I got out of the military and I
wanted to be a bodybuilder and then I
realized I'm 64 it's not going to work
for bodybuilding to win Mr Olympia
because everybody is 58 59 510 maybe 511
Ronnie Coleman but the 64 days are
behind us even L fno didn't win at that
height Arnold did and then when I got
into sales and everybody was a fan then
I started competing still a little bit
of fan but when I started the insurance
company and then I started growing
market share really then a lot of those
people that were fans then started
undermining and I said got it this is
how it works you can't be this naive you
can't be this innocent competition is
out there if you want to kind of go out
there and take market share from others
and you want to get bigger you can't
expect for people to sit there and like
everything you doing that's when I
realized you got to choose your enemies
wisely people want you to do well they
just don't want you to do better than
that yes yes yeah it's interesting
there's this story of Churchill and he's
showing a young MP Around the House of
Lords in the UK this is before World War
II you can imagine that they're
wandering through these Dusty hallways
over there's the toilet and over there's
where we have a cigar and blah blah blah
blah anyway they going to the chamber
they're going to the the House of Lords
right uh the difference actually the
distance between the two front benches
is the same distance as a long sword
held out at arms length from both sides
which is a Kind of a Funny vestage of
evidently what they were worried about
in the Middle Ages and they've just
continued to update but they've never
changed the distance of the front
benches anyway got this young guy who's
probably full of testosterone and you
know he's finally he's here with Winston
Churchill you go in and this young MP
starts gesticulating at the other side
he keeps referring to them as the enemy
Churchill turns to him and he says
that's the opposition Dear Boy the enem
is behind
you and I love that story the reason
that I love that story is that it often
reminds us that
symbolically We Believe that the biggest
obstacle we have to overcome is out
there and many times the call is coming
from inside of our own house I think
that the worst enemy that many people
have is the voice that's inside of their
own head now this voice has probably
maybe come from the outside world but
we've now internalized it you know we
have become Our Own Worst Enemy in some
regards yeah and by the way that's one
of the enemies that's one of the enemies
and there isn't one it's the famous uh
uh Matthew MCC speech that he's given
hey one guy asked me who's the greatest
actor in the world and he says sayy you
know I'll tell you and then you're like
I want to meet the 35y old version of me
and hey when I get to 35 you know I want
to 45 it's always looking forward to
what that next better version of you is
going to be but at the end of the day
even Alexander one of his famous quot
quotes is I have met the enemy it is I
right and although that is one element
of an enemy that's great we need that uh
Michael had it Brady had it Kobe had it
but
there's a there's a crazy
psychologically you can call it you know
psycho
competitor that they're constantly in
the search of recruiting their next
enemy it's it's like you know life is
boring if I don't have my next Target
you know I'm I'm almost you know bad for
myself if I don't have the next Target
the next enemy and if I choose it the
right way then I'm able to bring out a
side of me I've never seen before what's
the function of an enemy what is the
function of an enemy what is the
function of uh falling in love why do
you need to fall in love why do you need
to have it's enjoyable it's pleasurable
it's fulfilling but what does it do to
you though when you're in love you know
you know how they say when when a person
is in love and they go and test their
brains and it's like somebody that's on
drugs you've seen this before you
probably read this before right okay
so but what's the risk of
Love
heartbreak losing years of maybe you
love the wrong person maybe they don't
love you in return as much as you love
them maybe you're going to give more
than they're going to give you maybe a
betrayal maybe it's an act maybe it's
just good for the season maybe they're
going to change their minds if they
really find out what you're all there's
a lot of risk to love but why do we love
you know it's a very unique relationship
that risk is exhilarating it's exciting
you know maintaining it it's a lot of
work it's not easy it's why nowadays
most people don't want to get married
nowadays there's a movement of I don't
want to get involved to getting married
I don't want to have kids it's too risky
I want to live for myself I don't want
to have the responsibilities I don't
want to be heartbroken okay great I
think you know one time a friend of mine
and I Arash were in Italy and I rented
this place in uh uh Tuscan Italy this is
like 10 years ago and we're staying
there and Arash and I when we're
together we like to debate and we debate
about anything it doesn't matter what
the topic is anything okay he's like the
Middle Eastern Bradley Cooper too
good-looking of a guy one of those guys
kind of like you're a good-looking guy
he's a good-look guy so we have a
three-hour drive to chinka okay it's a
beautiful place you go to and it's a
long drive to go to it you know what
we're debating about love here's what
the question
was can you love somebody you know
Define love for me says love is a
feeling it's emotion it's this it's so
great I said say you're in jail your
wife is somewhere else how does she know
you love her how do you sure love is
love a verb is Love A Feeling is love a
noun we're having this conversation
right and then you realize the risk of
loving is worth it I can't imagine
living life without having that
love it introduces you to a person
you've not met before man a great enemy
does that as well a formidable enemy is
going to introduce you to a person
you've not seen before by the way could
be ugly could be scary could be oh my
God who is this person why are you
acting like this why are you thinking
like this so most of us when we it's
almost like that um the movie Venom it's
one of my son's favorite movie right the
Venom comes in like there's an there's
an ugly side to it if you lose control
of it right and you become Reckless and
you hurt people around you then you're
actually not good for yourself you're
destroying your own life that's why the
key word is what choose your enemies
wisely it's not it's not have an enemy
it's choose your enemies wisely if I
choose the right enemy and then I have
this relationship with this enemy
sometime it's a one month enemy it could
be a one week enemy it could be a one
day enemy it could be a lifelong enemy
because it's yourself because that's a
permanent
enemy and Just Like A Love Affair there
is an affair with this enemy it's
actually a beautiful thing I love the
idea of it bringing out a of you that
you didn't know bringing out a person
inside of you that you weren't aware
existed so I think there's a
um there's definitely a function to get
that into you come on crack it in
there's definitely a function to uh to
people looking to be well
balanced oh
yeah delicious good wow fantastic that's
what I want to here six months of taste
testing so I'm glad that it Tes to fly
to fly to Liverpool to do that there is
definitely a culture on the internet of
people wanting to ameliorate all of
their difficult and uncomfortable
emotions to transmute them into
something closer to equinity right
balance peace sanity and I've said this
a lot and I think that I'm quite averse
to uh Conflict by Nature that's the way
that I tend to operate uh I I often just
bow out opt for peace uh and then
two things changed first off I realized
that I'm leaving an awful lot of
motivation on the table okay by not
utilizing a very specific very potent
kind of fuel because I was aware that
over a long enough time span I think it
can be toxic I think that if you're
fueled by hate and distaste and fear and
scarcity for long enough it becomes
something that damages you more than it
helps you win but it's unbelievably
potent especially in times of war the
second second thing that happened was I
became a little bit more of a target for
people's ey and distaste and that meant
that the
underdog loving support that everybody
has for the person that's on the
comeup dissolved a little bit and
started to evaporate because people
don't mind you doing well they just
don't want you to do better than them
you know when you're on the way up
everyone roots for you because you
remind them of their dreams and when
you're at the top everyone tries to tell
L you down because you remind them of
what they gave up on so those two things
uh changed I had a great conversation
with Alex hosi that really drove this
home to me he said use what you have and
a lot of people have more pain than they
do pleasure don't use it for too long 10
15 20 years like that's how you end up
having a breakdown or some sort of
dependency or addiction or
vice but it's potent so use it and I
think that um the Insight of enemies can
bring out a side of you that you are not
aware you weren't aware even
existed is kind kind of like Alchemy
right it's turning something that is
both toxic and useless into something
which is golden and your
choice yes and by the way your eyes okay
I'm looking at your eyes right now your
eyes don't tell me a guy that is just
doing this to just have fun okay your
eyes have a lot of fire in them okay a
lot of fire in them uh you your eyes
tell a story of maybe you have a crazy
side uh sight inside of you okay
a side that maybe you keep inside okay
where very few people maybe see but
that's why you're doing as well as
you're doing I walk into this place I do
a lot of podcast I walk into this place
you chose I walk in I'm like Sam where
are we he says honestly I don't know but
I think we're at the right place we walk
in and I see why you do what you do and
the amount of time and resources and
your team putting into hand selecting a
different set we don't do that so what
does that tell me you're maniacal you're
detail oriented you got you're moving up
right now on the podcast across the
board competing with everybody you have
a vision maybe some of it we know
probably all of it we don't know okay
some of it's kept even the smiles
telling the story right now you're a
perfect example of this right uh um if
you and I sit down we get the benefit I
don't know if you read Elon musk's
recent book or not Walter not yet no
I've heard from every single person
that's even glanced at the blur that you
need to read it you need to read it
you're going to flip out you're going to
love it you'll appreciate it for a guy
that's wired like you
we get to judge Elon from the outside
okay why would
somebody you sell a company for $180
million you take $100 million you put it
in
a solar whatever you take 70 in Tesla
you put 10 in you know another Company
vice versa whatever the structure no you
put 100 million in SpaceX 70 million in
uh in uh Tesla and 10 million you put it
in solar then you're a billionaire then
you want to do what you want to go to
the next thing then boring company then
you got Twitter what for and you read a
story in the book about his father on
how his father was are you kidding me oh
I mean if you some of the biggest people
that we read about we watch movies about
it's one of their two parents that did
something to them I'm I'm with Tom Brady
a month ago we have him at the event and
the the the formula I see with a lot of
people that do something big as three
things one at one point in their lives
they they experience unconditional love
cuz you need it it's fuel you have to
have it even if it's just from one
person okay unconditional love means
what you screwed up you went to jail you
got a DUI you got kicked out of school
you got expelled everybody ousted you
and said you're a nobody you're not
going to mount to anything you're a
loser you're this but that mother there
always said honey I love you you can do
anything to lose this one person's love
one person it's all you need you don't
need need 50 of them just one
unconditional love number two is you
need somebody who brought Unbelievable
pain in your life that you loved this is
a person you and I loved that they
destroyed our heart we couldn't do
anything to gain love from this person
nothing perform tell and we love them go
above and beyond give them money buy him
gifts give them incredible experience es
become buff have a six-pack drive a
Ferrari have a Lambo own a penthouse
have a yacht be best friends with the
best athletes with billionaires no
matter what you do this person brought
you so much pain you can never win this
person over it is a battle your entire
life try to win this person over you're
never going to do it it's not going to
happen but you need that person as well
you know what the last one is obviously
choosing your enemies wisely you take a
person that has those three combination
by the way very rarely will they ever
tell you the entire reason very rarely
will they fully disclose everything some
of them will take you to their grave
with them we will never know about it
but for someone to have the kind of a
fire that goes years Beyond 99% of
people would have stopped what's the
reason for it what else do you need how
many more accolades how many more tens
of millions of dollars how many more
cars how many more houses how many more
top charts on podcast number one this
what's the reason for it
you know it's a uh again we're not
talking about everybody most people will
listen to this whole concept of choose
your enemies wisely and they'll say
that's hate what a miserable life what a
this what a that no most people chose
the wrong enemies the enemies they've
chosen is about being entitled it's
about being victim it's about feeling
sorry for themselves and it's destroyed
them it's stolen stolen years away from
their lives so yeah the the way you're
describing what you're saying you know
you'll typically c a pattern with those
three things of people uh who do
something big they experience those
three and unfortunately the reason why I
like musk's book is when you read it you
see the pattern with all three
unconditional love Mom and Kimble his
brother unconditional pain father
choosing his enemies wisely industry
traditional you know guys who are like
this is the way we do with NASA you know
governmental agencies censorship
you know establishment he's just
recruiting new enemies for himself every
day it's like bored he needs more
enemies and more enemies but guess who's
talking about him around the world
everybody is and 100 years from now our
kids our grandkids will look back and
say man who was this Elon musy
unfortunately we're not going to be
around to talk about who it was how how
how we viewed him but they're going to
be watching plenty of documentaries and
movies about a guy like that because he
chose his enemies wisely feels to me
I've got in my mind the image of uh man
you know when he is able to eat the
ghosts and the ghosts since were
previously a threat to him now become
Fuel and uh that to me is uh I learned
the three most common traits of elite
performers and it was a crippling sense
of insufficiency a superiority complex
and maniacal Focus Y and I think that
those three things map on to what you
were just talking about there have you
read this book I've read the first half
just so you know that part from your
podcast is in in the book you're in the
book did you know this or no no you're
in your podcast is in the book those
three things you just talked about okay
it's in the book hell yeah yeah hell
yeah so those three things right I'm
scared that I'm not enough I believe
that I can do more yeah I have the
impulse control to be able to keep me
focused and keep me moving
forward what would you say to the people
that say what you're describing sounds
an awful lot like a competitor okay yeah
what's the difference between a
competitor and an enemy yeah it's not a
competitor because to me uh so so in the
last 20 some years I have worked my tail
off to figure out a way of writing a
business plan that I can teach others
how to write a business plan so when you
go buy books on business plans it's all
boring technical it's for a Fortune 500
company or somebody that wants to go
raise capital and it's so complex and
dense you will not think about a
business planning book that you're going
to walk away and saying here's how I can
write a business plan that's simple that
I can look at it over and over and over
again great I'm good to go right there
isn't something like that out there this
is supposed to be a business planning
book that turned into an enemies book so
when I'm talking to the CEO the the
publisher of a portfolio
Okay uh Adrian and we're going back and
forth we had five hour zooms five one
hour zooms just on the title and in many
cases we would sit there for 15 minutes
no one's talking we're all who wanted
what who won what who wanted what so
they wanted to figure out a title that
was a straightup title like you know
like well how to Think and Grow Rich you
know how just a very much of a business
planning be the exactly something like
that and then eventually I'm selling
Adrien I'm saying but that's not what it
is this is much deeper than that it has
to do with enemies and eventually on the
fifth time of choosing the title guess
who finally says the title of the book
has to be choose your enemies wisely
Adrien does from portfolio and I said
That's thep you won it was a battle of
attrition it was a battle of attrition
we put a few hundred of them right but
but it's it's it's an interesting
concept when you're saying competition y
to me the 12 building blocks that I talk
about in this book you know we have
different uh categories because one side
of the building block has to do with
emotion the other side of the building
block has to do with logic and you read
this when you were going through the
book so on the emotion side you know
it's going to move us so for example I
what skill sets do I need to learn well
I need to learn how to do a podcast how
to ask questions how to do research you
told a Churchill story at the beginning
with the sword the size and hey your
enemies are not ahead of you they're
behind you okay you have to go find that
story that's content right okay so that
means you're constantly reading why is
this guy so good at what he does with
content okay he's very detailed look at
the lighting look how he does it look at
his sets he's intentional he's not
winging it everything you doing for the
most part 95% of it can be replicated by
somebody else but the 5% is your width
is your interest is the Curiosity either
the person has it or they don't have it
right okay so yes I can pick up those
skills but do I have your willpower
that's emotional yes I can go study the
competition let me see the top
podcasters out there what they're doing
what is a category for politics for
business for sports for comedy yes but
enem is bigger study competition all you
want but enem is a complete different
criteria that you're talking about you
can have all the money in the world
fantastic that's finances that's money
you can go raise money there's plenty of
companies that raise money quibby a few
years ago raised $2.3 billion from who
all the big money guys everybody gave
quibby money what happened to them
kenberg me Whitman everybody behind it
went out of business in
1962 1962 was a super saving Center
which is the year where Target came out
Walmart came out and Costco came out all
the same year 1962 okay in 1962 when
these companies came
out Kmart goes and raises a ton of money
5 years later Kmart has 250 locations
Walmart has nine locations 5 years later
Kmart on a leader bulletin within five
years guess who's winning Kmart's
dominating all logical all numbers
spreadsheet etc etc you couldn't tell me
the founder of Kmart who he is if I ask
who's the founder of K you're not going
to say Mr Kmart right that doesn't make
any sense what happened to Kmart a few
years ago Kmart goes out of business
they're no longer around you you know
how many employees Walmart has around
the world 2.3 2.5 million employees do
you know wal Sam Walton one of the best
books he can ever read is made on
America it's 200 Pages he walks to you
through how he built uh Walmart do you
know what his poorest kid is worth today
poorest kid is worth $50 billion today
he's got four of them can you imagine
these guys at Thanksgiving they're like
hey Johnny I noticed man you're only at
50 billion do I need to you know go fun
you know raise some money for you now
it's going to be all right you're going
to make make it through what's the moral
of the story The the story is one is
logic the other one is emotion emotion
brings out a different set if it can be
controlled Madness controlled emotion
it's going to go into a different gear
that a normal person is not going to
have we'll get back to talking to
Patrick in one minute but first I need
to tell you about
element element contains a science
backed electrolyte ratio of sodium
potassium and magnesium with no junk no
coloring no artificial ingredients or
any other BS it is a healthy alternative
to sugary electrolyte drinks and it's
how I've started my morning every single
day for over 3 years now you don't need
coffee first thing in the morning your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't even active for the first 90
minutes of the day but your adrenal
system is and salt acts on your adrenal
system best of all they have a nobs no
questions asked refund policy where you
can buy it and try it completely
risk-free and if you do not like it for
any reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box right now you can get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors of your
first box by going to the link in the
description below or heading to drink LM
nt.com slod wisdom that's drink LM
nt.com
slod wisdom let's talk competition
you're saying competitors right okay no
problem um in high school you can see
somebody who was the best basketball
player super competitive at that level
say they're tall they're 66 they can jum
40 in they have a quick first you know
step they're very athletic in every way
they're the best athlete in the county
even in the state for that position no
problem they go to college they can
compete but maybe they're coming off the
bench averaging 7.2 points a game three
rebounds two assists no problem they may
not make it to the NBA but let's just
say he makes it to the NBA plays a year
two years then he goes to Puerto Rico
then he goes to Spain then he plays in
Turkey then he plays in China 10 years
later never comes back to the NBA he's
out now he's an assistant coach in
Puerto Rico or somewhere else then
there's a guy that comes to the NBA he
compet
he's talented he's chosen to work he's a
very good worker stable guy doesn't do
the drugs doesn't do the alcohol he
hooks up with a lot of girls but he
doesn't get in the way he doesn't
respect you he respects his teammates
wives he doesn't do anything he plays
for 15 years makes $200 million good for
him then you have the psycho
competitor who counts the 55 kids ahead
of him that were chosen as the best high
school basketball player and he's ranked
number 56 and one by one by one he
targets every one of them until he takes
them out his name is Kobe Bryant then
you have Michael Jordan in 1984 where
the number one draft pick is aim alaguan
Fair good good selection for the Rockets
number two is s Bui I think Portland
picks him up or Seattle picks him up
number three is Michael Jordan you pick
me number three yes what happens to
Michael see these guys Michael was never
the highest paid guy in the NBA the only
time Michael was the highest paid guy in
the NBA was last year made 33 $30
million Scotty Pippen made more money in
the NBA than Michael Jordan ever made
Michael Jordan today's worth $3 billion
Scotty Pippen is not what's the
difference it's a very different mindset
Scotty's a competitor but he's not at
Michael's level by the
way it's very easy to criticize a guy
like you who wants to compete and maybe
internally you don't want to compete you
want to dominate maybe internally you
want to show everybody no I want to be
number one let's just say within because
professionally want to do this totally
cool
but there's a lot of other competitors
out there that have good podcasts and
they're doing a good job it's just a
different mindset when you have that
Enemy by the
way very rarely will those guys ever
truly again reveal their top driver and
the top enemy
why because it's it's a it's an element
of insecurity yeah it's a signal of low
status it is it's and it's also I don't
want to give the other person credit I
don't want to give that other person
more power than the person thinks they
have you don't have power or because
somebody may be like Oh I'm your enemy I
control you exactly well when it's a
part of the come up story yeah it's
romantic right it's it's uh it's
Grassroots it's what's keeping you going
look at look at how I was mistreated by
my first High School coach they didn't
see the T I'm going to prove it to them
that's a beautiful origin story age
20 age 45 that just sounds like someone
who can't get the chip off his shoulder
yeah so yeah I think it's it's
interesting how the tools that got you
here aren't the ones that will get you
there and how the strategy this is again
one of the reasons why continuing to
rely on resentment and bitterness and
the chip on your shoulder and enemies
for too long becomes a very toxic Fuel
and it's also importantly optic are very
very important it's a signal of low
status okay you brought I don't disagree
but you brought up a story of Churchill
right okay the world is weeks away from
all speaking
German okay if we lose the world and the
guy wins no problem
Chamberlain cannot hold it together and
the story about how the only way
Churchill said it was going to come back
is for Chamberlain to come and beg him
the only way
does it sound like something Churchill
would do by the way absolutely yeah
Churchill sat there and said okay he has
to come and ask me cuz Chamberlin sent
other people he said no no no no no only
one person has to come look at me face
to face and say you can do a job I can't
do come back and help us think about
think about that
now visualize that scene we can see it
in a movie or we can read in a book and
by the way say 50% of it is true the
other 50% is true right the other 50% is
a lie and it's like build up mythical
over Generations right I believe that
Churchill would want to hear it from a
Chamberlain have you heard of
Churchill's Ministry of ungentlemanly
Warfare no so this is a phenomenal book
that everybody can go and read uh before
the second world war it was considered
ungentlemanly to use Guerilla style
tactics and in fact one of the uh
British politicians said something to
the effect of if this is what it takes
to win the war I am prepared to lose
they were the Brits saw anything shy of
gentlemanly Conduct in war as a loss
even if it resulted in a win and
Churchill came in and changed that he
was the one that changed that culture so
he puts together this crack Squad of
eccentric weirdos one guy invents the
Limpet mine right which you can descend
to depth and then it'll attach using
magnets and it'll blow things up another
group uh develop what is the uh
predecessor to the SAS another group are
working on disguises and and Guerilla
tactics to disrupt infrastructure as the
German Advance is trying to move forward
uh so yeah Churchill was prepared to
play dirty but you know you look at the
tactics that were used they only came
about because of one man who legitimated
it and and he said we will do whatever
it takes to win now here's the thing
when you hear a story like that um
somebody may say well you know what a
what a what a coldblooded bastard oh my
God no wonder people hate him no wonder
he is who he is where many president
moved the bust of Churchill in the White
House away and said take this out so I
don't represent what he represents
everybody acts all hard right we can
hate a Churchill during peace time but
during wartime you you beg for a
Churchill to rise up wartime leaders
like Churchill you only appreciate dur
ring War time there's a a really
interesting Insight from evolutionary
psychology here there's two types of
leadership one is from dominance and the
other is from Prestige right one is uh
more authoritarian it's tyrannical it's
very aggressive the other is uh more
altruistic it's uh
the the rise to power is denoted it's
spread through the group everybody
chooses together that this is someone
who we all believe has the skills and
the dominance is not the same and there
are specific times when you want
dominance and when you want Prestige and
in times of conflict you want dominance
sure sure you could say it in business
it's startup versus when it's more
established right but here's also the
thing like the part where you got to
give a lot of credit to Steve Jobs Steve
Jobs had a startup mentality and then he
took that to the company and then he
hires you know his Scully that comes in
from Pepsi and he says you want to sell
sugar can you know water for the rest of
your life or you want to change the
world he brings him in then he ends up
being the reason to fire jobs jobs
leaves goes builds Pixar sells it to
Disney most of his wealth is tied to
Disney not at Apple then he comes back
and he realizes that style of leading is
not going to work to take the company to
the next level when he comes back to
Apple the first phone call he says he
says the idea of thinking Microsoft is
the enemy is behind us we can't think
like that anymore this is what Steve
Jobs says and he goes to Microsoft and
he gets $300 million from Microsoft
to invest into apple and these guys
hated each other Microsoft came out in'
76 Apple came out in 77 a year apart and
everybody was always comparing the two
together Bill Gates ended up being much
richer than Steve Jobs but Steve Jobs
was admired way more than Bill Gates so
what does this mean the individual has
to evolve like you have to also recreate
yourself as you're going through this
the same enemy that drives you when
you're 22 years old should not be
driving you at 32 years old or else
haven't matured you should also outm
mature that enemy and then 32 something
else should be driving you then 42 then
58 then 63 then 75 but you are going to
have those love affair with those
enemies that's a love affair you had an
affair with this enemy over an 8-year
span over a 13ear span over a six-year
span over a six- month span but you know
there is truth in the idea of you still
being driven by that enemy 18 years
after you beat that enemy 13 years after
you beat that enemy someone who I think
is particularly good at creating enemies
from modern pop culture and our industry
is Ben Shapiro okay what do you think
about what he's doing at Daily wire from
a enemy perspective and and generally
you talking about recently with his Feud
with Tucker Carlson or period generally
everything overall um I think Tucker is
a True Believer I think Tucker is not
somebody that if he's doing it
intentionally to get under your skin
let's say that's 20% let's say it's 10%
because he's witty and he's smart and
he's sharp Tu or Ben I'm sorry Ben Ben
Shapiro is who you're talking about
right yeah let's say Ben is doing that
10 or 20% intentionally to get under
your skin okay but this guy at a young
age wanted to be Supreme Court just you
know he's been wanting to be that for a
long time this is not a regular guy I
think at 12 or 13 years old he performed
in front of a couple thousand people his
level of intelligence of how early on he
got a degree went to college 15 16 years
old did all the stuff that he did so
he's a 100% True Believer does he have
an element that he can talk to somebody
and say I can murder you in a debate
right now if you really want to go there
yes he has that element as well yeah
does he have a side of him that's a
maybe a bully type a little bit sure
well don't forget during school he was
very heavily bullied himself very
heavily bullied but that's what happens
typically to people like C but that may
be the number one
driver that he's continuing because he
wants for the rest of his life for those
bullies to talk about that Ben shap used
to be a classmate what makes him go at
the pace that he goes you think it's
just all these other guys that we see
there's no way you think he would ever
tell us you think his own family knows
that highly doubt it it's to himself
many of these people that he has in his
life anybody that goes at that pace like
tuer Carlson today I don't know if you
saw the approval he got I think they got
$150 million today from some
organization who did organization yeah
so finally today the ward is out that he
raised money it's it's 100 it's a big
amount of money that he finally raised
today who's his enemy he's got a very
easy enemy he's got Fox News former
employer as an enemy he's got a lot of
political people as an enemy people with
silus him as an enemy you know how many
enemies Tucker's got you think Tucker
needs another $300 million that he has
in a bank account I highly doubt so he's
doing it for a complete different reason
because he wants to give the middle
finger to five 10 15 different people in
his life you just sense it with tuck by
the way you know what's wild right now
Ben Shapiro went after Tucker this week
what happened because of uh uh Israel
Tucker's position where he says we
should focus on 100,000 uh uh people in
America that are dying from fentanyl not
focused on what's going on in Israel and
Gaza and Ben Shapiro says you know we
can chew gum and walk at the same time
specifically from the moral standpoint
we can handle two different moral issues
but you know they're going back and
forth whether it's a seasonal thing or
not that's a complete different you know
competition that we're talking about
well I
suppose uh how would you say enemies of
convenience are sometimes good for
Optics you know what have we just seen
Dylan danis Logan Paul KSI Tommy Fury
Jake Paul Tommy Fury Logan Paul Jake
Paul and
uh who's the Jiu-Jitsu guy stocked in
slaps Diaz thank you Nate Diaz love that
guy enemies of convenience yeah you know
like nothing gets people's tongues
wagging more than you creating a little
bit of a feud on the internet do you see
uh they announced yesterday speaking of
feuds and speaking of Disney that the
daily wire are going to do that own
version of Snow White with Brett Cooper
starring as Snow White I saw that I saw
that I mean that to me is you know
largely a uh declarative statement of
culture war on what's happening with
children with children's movies you know
it's synthesizing down all of the little
tangential issues that have been
included is it anything to do with the
push toward the sort of books that are
in school is it us you know denying this
uh Rachel Ziggler Zigler throwing Snow
White under the bus like she doesn't
have a prince charming she has a stalker
we don't need that what do you think
about
that I think that it is a very dangerous
lesson to teach young girls that boys
that show interest in them are dangerous
and to be avoided I think it makes for a
generation of fragile narcissistic
fearful young girls that I wouldn't want
as a daughter and that I don't want as a
mother you know what a perfect example
that
is the movement of feminism is the
ultimate example of not choosing your
enemy
wisely you chose men as being the enemy
40 years later 50 years later you're 65
years old single not married no kids
you're living in an apartment or a condo
with a dog or a cat that that's all you
ever talk about and you're lonely and
you're sitting there saying I was wrong
men are not the enemy but guess what
that movement stole 50 years of your
life you how painful that is what what
she's doing right now with the messaging
she's giving and then getting out there
and saying well I don't want to be able
to have to do this no you know what it's
not necessarily going to be that way
nowadays you know women don't need that
anymore it's a complet different era
right now we're talking about and to do
this at a hundredy year anniversary of
Disney yeah really with what Walt and
many of us I remember living in Iran
watching Disney cartoons translated in
farsy literally in fary it it's it's
very weird when you watch it in farsy
cuz the language is a rough language you
know you give watch Pinocchio in farsy
it's not as appealing right but we grew
up with this stuff you know we grew up
with watching these cartoons to see that
taking place is uh if you ask me it's
absolutely pathetic but you're seeing
how many back to backto back flops
Disney has right now yeah and it's not a
good look by the way the buyers who want
to buy Disney they're loving this
Apple's one of the most qualified buyers
they they hope Disney makes five more
flops Apple sitting there saying make
five more flops Iger please by the way
wait have you read the right of a
Lifetime by Bob AER okay another
interesting guy what he did with his
38th career at ABC obviously he's been
there a lot longer but when you read the
book the first 38
run to be one of the best power Brokers
than to finish your career up the way
you're doing right now very very bad way
of finishing it up he's not an idiot
right you don't have the excuse of not
knowing he is for sure what a point you
just made he is 100% not an idiot this
guy was about to run for president Bob
Iger was going to he was one of the guys
that everybody was trying to get to run
for president him and Oprah they were
supposed to be this literally this was
the conversation so he also ended up
choosing the wrong enemies and the wrong
allies not realizing your best allies
are parents you're losing parents who
have been watching this for years you're
losing the people that this is a legacy
product it's another example of a
complete screw up that's going to come
out a discount for somebody else like
Apple I mean look at to go back to Ben
and what Jeremy are doing over the daily
wire uh Hershey's do a campaign that
they don't like within five days they've
released their own chocolate bar uh that
shaving company does something they
don't like within 24 hours maybe they
filmed a video with a McLaren for
Jeremy's razor they don't like the way
fantastic commercial by the way well
done Jeremy's got Jeremy's got skills I
listen to him and Shapiro talking about
the fact that originally Jeremy was the
talent and Ben was the money man and the
the the uh data guy behind the scenes do
you know Zack Levi I think his name is
Zack Levi the actor who played the uh
what is the movie the the the the the
superhero for kid movies what is the
guy's name what is it B no it's aent
you're the one with like yeah four kids
yeah trust me I've seen this movie a
couple times he he played Kurt Warner a
recent movie that came out the American
Underdog he played Kurt Warner him and
Jeremy used to have a production company
apparently 1015 years ago and Zach ended
up being a big time actor in Hollywood
doing very good for himself and by the
way Jeremy is another great example of a
guy that's got enemies just look at his
eyes when you talk when you hear Jeremy
speak you see the fire built for enemies
he's got enemies and he wants to take
those enemies out but that's why I
thought the daily y was an illustrative
example because they are as far as I can
see largely a company built on
identifying enemies you know they're
very much in opposition to ideas that
they don't like to movements they don't
like to people that they don't like and
uh yeah man I mean it's you have to be
built for that you really really do need
to be built for it and it certainly
seems to me that what Ben and what
Jeremy are doing over there is
purpose-built to be the anti this the
anti that and a lot of the time it's new
movements that they don't just they
don't agree with the Market's going to
prove if the concept is going to work or
not and if can sustain because if it's a
built TOA concept they're going to be
they're going to succeed but can
somebody else come and pick up that
concept and continue with that with the
same level of fire it's going to take a
couple decades to figure that part out
it's interesting to think you know from
from our side when you see those Rachel
Ziggler interviews and she's saying
courting is stalking um a girl doesn't
need to be saved by a prince you know
she's busy thinking about how she can
fulfill her own dreams and becoming the
woman that she always knew that she
could so and so forth you think a lot of
people are is that really the you know
the highest manifestation Is that real
self-actualization for young women
nowadays that's the question they ask
and you're totally right that look
ultimately the market will choose
there's no question about it the market
will choose the market is brutal you
know you know what's the great thing
about it's always right it's always
right you know you can you can say well
let me tell you I'm the best bodybuilder
in the world yeah okay look at your
calves yeah good luck to you go put
those little skimpy
you know uh shorts on and see what your
you know legs look like no you're not as
good as you think you are you're full of
it yeah Market is brutal podcast
business Concepts Investments drinks you
know alcohol books you write when we
first wrote uh when I first wrote your
next five moves and we launched it
August of 2020 this is during the peak
of coid my publisher Simon Ander asking
says so how do you think the book's
going to do how you going to judge the
book me and Greg dinkin are talking I
said if the book is doing well 3 years
from now it was a good book you can have
a great marketing campaign the book does
well the first 30 60 90 days but is the
book selling 3 years later if it is
that's a great book because a market
will tell you
that yeah very interesting to think
about how Optics and there are ways to
game the system and I think people are
very they're hyper aware of this they
understand that there are people who
have managed to use tactics and hacks to
get themselves into a position that they
maybe didn't quite deserve that the
legitimacy of the product the book or
whatever it is the person
who maybe uh when Megan markle's
autobiography comes out perhaps people
would accuse her of doing something like
this right it's not to do with the
actual product it's to do with the
positioning and sometimes that does work
but
ultimately form is temporary and class
is permanent naval's got this great
quote where he says um karma is just
people repeating their beliefs actions
and behaviors until they finally get
what they deserve you just roll the dice
you keep rolling the dice right every
single time every single thing you do
the way that you interact with the Uber
driver the way that you pay or don't pay
the bill or invoice that you've got
every tiny little thing each time is an
opportunity for your true nature to come
out and people just keep on rolling the
dice keep on rolling the dice and then
every so often someone hits double one
and you go oh there we go but it's
temporary you can't do permanently Megan
Merkel whether her motives are really
because she loves The Prince and it's
like Harry she's in love with him or
she's using the power to bully and get
what she wants out of it the market is
brutal look what happened to Amber herd
for how many years did everybody think
you know Johnny Depp was a bad guy for
how many years oh Johnny Depp was an
abusive you know relationship all this
stuff and then they start showing the
clips the videos and Johnny's
comfortable with it being published
and all of a sudden
180 the world is like what an [__]
she is not him I love Johnny the next
thing you know the love of her was like
how many more men are going through like
Johnny is and then how many women said
she ruined it for women who were
actually abused correct so yeah for a
longest time oh my God crying so such a
so difficult time what he was so when he
hit me we fell for it but we were will
only fall forward temporarily not
permanently the market will reveal
eventually hopefully yeah I again man
form is temporary class is permanent and
people will ultimately get what they
deserve uh when it comes to the courting
is
stalking culture that we have at the
moment you've got a daughter you've got
young Sons you also spend some time
under value tainment talking about
intersexual Dynamics and what's going on
between the Sexes what do you make of
the current dating scene for men and and
why do you think it's being demonized in
some ways from what perspective from I
think that there is an anti-dating
culture at the moment okay I think that
men and women are being encouraged to be
treated as equals uh sorry as
adversaries not as equals right right um
I think it's transactional today I think
it's easy today I think the swipe right
Community is it's Friday night 11 o'cl
let me swipe right I'm going to use 20
someone's going to get back to me if
they swipe right and they so and
typically I would go after turn 8 and 1
half n but it's Friday night I'm going
to go do a 6 and A2 7 no one's going to
know I'm going to invite her back to my
place she knows if she's on Tinder I'm
not on Bumble whatever these dating apps
are and so it's transactional strategic
no one's going to know and literally not
a lot of people going to know you can
really run through 20 40 50 100 nowadays
and it's not a big deal okay so what
does that do whatever is too easy to
come you devalue it you don't value it
that highly you know my era you had to
Court you had to prospect you had to
have scripts you had to build
relationship you had to follow up we
didn't have these types of things to do
we had Myspace the last time I was
single there was Myspace okay I DMD uh
my wife on MySpace my wife and I knew
each other for five and a half years
eventually we're in Palm Springs for the
first time she's single I'm single ever
for five and a half years we're both
single and you know we go on a date
first date PF chank December 29th of
2007 used this when pfchang used to be
good one they had their their their
noodle soup they don't have it anymore
used to be they took that away
phenomenal item on the menu I'm
convinced they they fell apart after
that so anyways we go to PF CHS by the
way if you're watching bring it back it
was actually very good item on the menu
so we go on a date there's magic she's
smiling I'm smiling you know the smile
that's kind of like I'm happy to see you
and then it's midnight where the last
people left at pfchangs you know waiter
comes up to me and and he says what's
going on I said you know my wife wants
to file a divorce she doesn't want to be
with me anymore so your wife why yeah I
come from a different religious
background and her family's convinced we
got to split up and he has no clue we're
not married we're just on our first date
he sits down for 15 minutes convincing
her to stay with me if you love him stay
with him it was a beautiful you know
scene that we have we go in the car she
goes home the next day I take her we go
do stairs in Santa Monica we go to
church we go to Earth Cafe in Santa
Monica then we go to border ERS I buy
her book on our second date called 101
questions to ask before you get engaged
on our second date by Norman Wright
She's like what's this I said I'm not
looking for a girlfriend I'm looking for
a wife I'm 28 at the time uh I said I
know exactly what I want I've already
done this exercise with three other
girls if you want to go through it great
you need to answer the questions let's
meet up when you're ready and let's go
through it week later 6 hours at her
place one by one by one each question we
go through I said this is somebody I can
date and by the way it's ugly cuz you
got to talk about everything in the book
so
today that's not it anymore today it's
too risky today it's you don't have
access to that anymore today percentages
are coming out where marriages from
dating sites have the least chance of
working out versus marriages where you
meet somebody through a referral where
you say Pat I've known Mary for seven
years I think you and her should talk
now I don't know what's going to happen
let me set you guys up let's take our
girls and do a double day cool hey I
kind of like her this is but you're
telling me seven years I've only seen
her be with one guy Larry 5 years he was
an [__] then she's been with this
other guy two years but she's single now
now I have some kind of a history I'm
dealing with
right so it is a different climate now
with kids it's a different story on how
you raise them uh my 10-year-old son
he's he's been he's had a girlfriend
since he was 5 years old literally at a
birthday party at 5 years old he's
making out with this other girl at this
Damon bu DAV Busters I'm like babe what
is going on his mom is asking me you
know our kids are kissing I said well I
got a son you got daughter you may want
to stop your daughter but I'm not going
to stop my son so she's like well guys
guys no stop stop they don't even know
what's going on so there's you need to
have the conversation with kids early
today uh I remember having conversation
with my boys when they were six and five
in the shower and I said okay we need to
have this conversation together what's
that okay stand up that's your dangling
that's his dangling this is my dangling
only you get to play with your dangle
link one day you're gonna find a girl
that's gonna play with your dangle link
till then God gave you that dangling for
only you to play with your dangling now
you got to see how they're looking at me
by the way they're looking at me like
this and my wife leaves quickly she's
like babe this is UNCA babe you can
leave so we have that conversation I
think you need to have the conversation
today because most parents are on Middle
Eastern they don't have those types of
conversations no one's talking about sex
and condoms and all this kind of stuff
you need to start early but the dating
scene
today very very different than what it
was when I was single uh I if I wanted
to go date to today and find a wife my
Approach would be very different than
what most people are doing
today very different we'll get back to
talking to Patrick in one minute but
first I need to tell you about Shopify
Shopify is the e-commerce platform
revolutionizing businesses all over the
world whether you're a garage
entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify is the
only tool that you need to start run and
grow your business online without the
hassle Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the United States and if
they are good enough for huge Brands
like gym shark they are good enough for
you too Shopify puts you in control of
every sales channel so whether you're
selling satin sheets from shopify's
inperson POS system or offering organic
olive oil on Shopify allinone e-commerce
platform they've got you covered and
once you've reached your audience
Shopify has the internet's best
converting checkout to help you turn
browsers into buyers if you are someone
who is looking to start a business
online Shopify is the only place to go
they are a One-Stop shop to create your
business so if you are looking to take
your business to the next level you can
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
right now by going to the link in the
description below or heading to
shopify.com
sodern wisdom in all lowercase that's
slod wisdom you say to be impressed by
the right things and you just suggested
at that as well what are the right
things what should people be impressed
by in what area in relationship no in
life in life what is it that people are
miscellaneously being impressed by that
they shouldn't be okay so your guy Chase
right wherever Chase is okay okay right
there and then uh your uh where's uh de
where's Dina Dina's in the back okay
you're telling me about Dean and what
Dean does he's been with you two years
three years you said 2 200 episodes and
how many uh uh 700 episodes two and a
half thousand videos 2 and half th000
videos 700 episodes okay what does that
say about you a lot okay if somebody
works with you for six years what are
they going to learn about you your
temper your expectation hey boys are we
ready this is all standard an
expectation expectation that you have
that is a reflection of he likes working
with you why does he like working with
you I don't know but you do something
right for him to want to work with you
and you told me what you're doing with
them structure that's private stuff that
you told me so you watch people you
watch values principles you watch how
they treat people you watch how people
treat them you watch how people respond
to them you watch how they are with
powerful people you watch how they are
with regular average day-to-day people
you
you look for that today it's not the
cars the the Lambos the Ferraris the
houses all that stuff by the way I'm a
capitalist and I love all that stuff but
I like that stuff because different
reasons I enjoy the game I'm a kid uh uh
I'm turning 45 tomorrow I'm 44 today for
the last day tomorrow I'll be 45 but
there's an element of childlike stuff
that brings out the 14-year-old kid when
I look at a baseball card I'm a kid when
look at a baseball C the average
person's like who cares about baseball
cards that's a different element
but the relationships the way Tre they
treat people values and principles what
they value you look for those types of
things and eventually enough will be
revealed the more you pay attention
that's one of the byproducts I think
that is dangerous sometimes of people
who play the game that they get captured
by The Game and they forget that it is a
game and they see the game as reality
they don't realize that there is
something which is supposed to to be
deeper which is hidden below the surface
so I did Rogan's show last year uh and I
listened back to the episode he said
something on it that I really wanted to
dig into and he listened back I listened
back and and pulled this this really
really powerful insight for me it was
one of the most powerful things I
learned last year and he said just
because something is hard to obtain does
not mean that it is
valuable just because something is hard
to obtain doesn't mean it's valuable
correct yeah just because it's difficult
to get does doesn't mean that it's
valuable look at the car he's driving
look at the watch he's wearing look at
the girl he's with these things were
hard to obtain so you presume that they
were valuable but you didn't realize
that what's genuinely Val valuable are
friendships and relationships and a
comfort and a confidence in yourself and
peace of mind and Sanity and being able
to positively impact the people around
you so it got me thinking I've been
really sort of reflecting on this over
the last year uh and I did some research
into the history of the pineapple so uh
1492 Christopher Columbus land on the
island of Guadalupe and for the first
time ever a Westerner sees a pineapple
right you look at it it's kind of a
royal fruit it's got this stupid crown
on its head and he writes in his journal
he describes the taste of a pineapple if
You' never had a pineapple before it'
blow your head off you know if you
haven't got processed food I remember
the first time I had a pineapple so
sweet it's insane of course anyway they
take a shipload literally back to uh the
Prince of Spain uh Prince Aragon
II take this entire ship back one of
them makes it that isn't
and the prince is allowed to eat it and
again it almost gets this sort of
mythical quality to it the pineapple
very quickly the British quite rightly
so they uh they start to see it as this
symbol of opulence right they see it as
this symbol of wealth so they would
parade pineapples around at dinner on a
platter and they would use them over and
over and over again you could rent a
pineapple right for the evening this is
the sort of house in which you might be
able to see a pineapple
right castles had pineapple uh statues
on the top of them there would be uh
fountains with pineapples at the front
of someone's
estate all of this occurred because of
the scarcity of a pineapple it was 8,000
to get one pineapple wow right that was
the equivalent back then £8,000 it was a
symbol of of privilege and opulence and
wealth and what it meant was that people
really looked up to this one object then
the French couple hundred years later
they invent green houses and that allows
us to grow tropical fruits at higher
climates higher uh uh
latitudes price drops and guess what no
one starts parading the pineapple around
anymore the scarcity of it was largely
determining the value of
it and that story and what I called
Rogan's value difficulty conflation just
because something is hard to obtain does
not mean that it is valuable now I would
argue that a pineapp is valuable no
matter how hard or difficult it's like a
dialed fruit no matter how good or how
difficult it is to get a hold of but I
really love that Insight because I think
that it shows how nonv valuable but
difficult to obtain things get slipped
into our desires I see that particular
expensive possession that intrinsically
I don't actually care about maybe I've
never been a watch guy maybe I've never
been a shoes guy maybe I've never been a
car guy but I want it I want it CU it's
hard to get okay well what if is a
quicker route toward fulfillment what if
there is a more direct path because
there are some people out there for whom
Keeping Up With the Jones is a
materialism is an inbuilt part of their
life but I can say as someone that
doesn't have that bone in my body
particularly that for me material
possessions they don't make a massive
difference to my quality of life I like
nice things I like to fly business I
like you know I like a nice house and
blah blah blah but there's people who
are tuned into that right maybe it was
their upbringing their genetic
predisposition whatever whatever
whatever but I think that people should
be very cautious why is it that I'm
chasing this thing am I chasing this
thing because it's something which is
valuable or am I chasing it simply
because it's something that's difficult
to get yeah that's a by the a very good
story and a great quote I remember in
Iran pineapple is on onas that's how we
say it we say Onan us and anybody in
Iran who had pineapple you were Rich two
things pineapple and banana in Iran only
rich people have pineapple and two good
fruits yeah two good fruits and then I
go to Germany and bananas are everywhere
but the first time I had pineapple I had
it in the states I couldn't believe we
were having pineapple I thought we were
Rich when we had pineapple I said Mom
are we finally rich here we made it we
retired on a pineapp retired yeah it was
on us and I remember I was in ninth
grade first time ever we went and ate at
Sizzlers I thought we had made it I'm
like guys you will not believe what
restaurant I don't know if you know
Sizzlers but Sizzlers in US is not a
fancy restaurant I thought we made it
because we ate at sizzors yeah you know
it's
say I used to think
um and and you know this whole concept
of people who are too much about fancy
things it's kind of like well look at
this guy all he cares about his money
all he cares about his fancy things all
he cares about is these cars and life
with the Rich and Famous and all this
other stuff eventually I realized not
everybody is driven by the same thing
all I care about that's something that
drives you okay my oldest son could care
less you know what he wants for a car
his favorite car a Jeep that's his dream
car my daughter says I want a white
Ferrari okay and I said who do you think
is going to buy that for you well Daddy
you're going to buy I said I'm not
buying you a white Ferrari you're going
to buy yourself a white Ferrari Dylan
wants a complete different car my oldest
son you know what you know what is
absolutely a great day for him outside
in the dirt playing with lizards
catching animals playing with dogs and
cats that's an incredible Day by the way
he's been like that since eight months
nine months my youngest son 10 years old
first time I take him to my barber to
get a haircut
and one of the girls at this place they
give uh massages at the end when you get
the haircut my oldest son says don't
touch my back don't don't touch me he
would go like this she's like no no dad
I don't tell her do not to touch me
right but my 10-year-old son it was five
at the time she's like can you also
massage me over here oh he likes the
Finer Things in life he lik the Finer
Things in life right my oldest son loves
dogs he loves animals my youngest son
don't get on my bed get off my bed my
oldest son wants a dog right next to him
the youngest son doesn't want any of the
dogs next to him and his dad loves dogs
I love animals right so I'm not I'm not
you know I think uh Joe specializes in
doing the heart if there's anybody that
specializes in doing the heart is Joe
you kid me like Joe is a uh enamored by
doing the heart but also Joe's learned
to be so self-aware of himself to know
what he likes I said Joe what do you
think about sports is uh I know nothing
about sports I don't watch sports the
only thing I watch is UFC Joe now that
you're getting all these eyeballs what's
your vision what if we can do this Pat
the only thing I want to do is I just
want to do podcast yeah I want to go
hunt I want to be my family I want to do
UFC this is all I want to do the level
of clarity he has of where he's at props
to him now Dana White slightly different
Dana is now worth a few hundred so he's
worth a half a billion dos today why is
he still driving why is he still pushing
why is he still competing why is he
still wanting to be number one who's his
enemy he drives running nice cars likes
to go to the likes to be around with
people having fun late night two
different Dynamics two different
personalities look at the organization
they built with u i mean thinking of
someone who chooses their enemies
tactically Dana is not someone who's shy
of a fight he loves it you know if you
were to think of a sea sweet level
fighter Dana White is is pretty well the
crap yeah you've you've spent a good bit
of time sort of orbiting that that whole
crew of people what have you learned
from your uh insights about the UFC and
and sort of what that says about Dana
oh
listen what I'm about to say about danam
is some people are not going to like it
but I'm I'm gonna say it anyways UFC is
what UFC is because of Dana White you
can sit there and talk about all these
Fighters and yeah but you know if it
wasn't for this guy if it wasn't for
that guy if it wasn't for what this
person did and that totally get it
listen different players come and go
right totally
understand uh Dana has made a about the
sport he never made it about the fight
uh he never made it about one fighter he
is very quick to call out anybody it
doesn't matter if it's the number one
guy in the league he'll call him out Jon
Jones he'll call out Conor if he screws
up but he'll back him up to the highest
level he'll say that was some stupid
[__] he did he'll sit there and straight
up tell you what he likes what he
doesn't like but everybody learned
during coid he was the number one
commissioner in all of sports every
commissioner in America k caved NBA
caved NFL caved MLB caved every
commissioner caved except for one guy
who had brass balls called Dana White
who said I don't give a [__] we're going
to find a place to do the fight so
during coid you know what's the only
sport the world watched we watched UFC
no one's watching a freaking football
game with no fans out there on
cardboards what am I going to do with
cardboards oh no we're going to watch
hey you can buy the seat for your face
to be on the you know basketball game
who gives a [__] it was the most boring
Finals Lakers won ever they shouldn't
even deserve to have won that final
there was no audience nobody boo against
you but everybody realized here's Dana
as a commissioner then is everybody else
you're not at his level he's a wartime
uh leader as well as a peacetime leader
he's learned how to prestige moving
together he said something in an
interview he says listen man maybe it's
just the fact that I'm getting old and
I'm getting soft but I have a hard time
seeing what's going on with some of
these guys and you know in the way his
personal life when he went through that
crisis and the way he put it he says you
want me to be embarrassed how much more
embarrassed you want me to be you know
how embarrassing it is to talk to my
wife and my kids you know how
embarrassing that is this is nothing
compared to embarrassing to have to face
my
kids you respect that you love that
there's a degree of clarity especially
to Dana that is very rare and I think
that one of the things the UFC's done is
make boxing particularly feel so
Antiquated and pedestrian and the fact
that KSI almost be Fury you know how bad
that would have been for boxing that's
not good that's not good but he KSI does
not represent UFC either uh he doesn't
but what would have happened if a
YouTuber would have beaten a
professional boxer with a last name of
Fury it's humiliating correct many
people would have said he could have won
Under points but what was it that you
said you made some comparison about
jockey and horses to do with Dana
White yes I made the analysis with he
musk where you either bet on the the
same goes with Dana White as well though
yeah so you got the jockey and the horse
okay you got Dana White is the jackey
the hores UFC Elon Musk is the
jackey Tesla is the horse okay so if
tomorrow Elon Musk resigned from Tesla
to only do Twitter what happens to
Tesla it's going to be disturbing for a
lot of investors because a lot of people
bought Tesla because it's Elon Musk a
lot of people are selling Tesla and
getting rid of their cars like AOC it's
Elon Musk ever since yeah he bought
Twitter double EDG sword yeah it's a
double edged sword but you know to me in
a perfect world is if you can have both
I think UFC is a great product
phenomenal product addicting product
okay viral product uh but Dana White is
an incredible Jackie do you remember
someone brought up I think it was Israel
had a sun had been using the nword and
it's at the press conference I mean it
must be fun for the Press you know to
sit down and Dana sits down he goes all
right guys what's going on the gate
tonight was we broke this he would did
fight of the nights and then he just
looks up and someone asks him a question
and he just says what he thinks you know
he doesn't say something that the media
team has prepped him on although I'm
sure he's got training and he
understands the boundaries but nothing
feels
prescribed uh
manufactured seated uh nothing contrived
nothing feels like that it just feels
like this is what the guy thinks uh
someone I I saw this on the internet
someone had talked
about many organizations and YouTubers
at the moment are trying to speedrun
authenticity right they're trying to
growth hack relatability how can I make
myself seem more authentic and relatable
than I actually am obviously it's kind
of a self-defeating prophecy which is
that the only way to be authentic is to
be authentic and there's a degree of
trust you know I mean Dana dude the
start of this year was rough for him
that him and his Ms got into a scuffle
and it got videoed and it was maybe like
New Year's Eve or something like oh
January 1st guess I was starting 2023
the worst way possible and he comes out
and you have faith that you go yeah this
guy meant what he said there I don't
think that there's any demons looking in
the closet because and I may regret
saying that at some point in future but
I don't think that I'm going to need to
because I just have faith that I'm not
Dana White I don't have stock in Dana
White I just I'm a good judge of
character and I see in him someone that
seems to tell the truth more often than
not and seems to be very open and honest
and own his mistakes and people love
that people really really like that so
yeah it makes him incredibly likable ath
authenticity at the highest level that
brand is a very authentic brand he he's
had his you know his enemies he's had
the people that have challenged him and
given him a hard time but Dana in in a
past life could have been a gangster
maybe he was but he could have been a
gangster he could have ran a family
that's how Dana is he could have been he
Dana is almost not a mob boss you know
of a Gambino family or geneves or
Columbo Dana's more the guy that ran the
commission like a luchano that's Dana
and to be that
guy there is no book you can read to be
that you can read 40 lot of 100 times
you can't be that guy you either are
that guy or you're not that guy big boss
energy Dana is that guy Dana is that
guy one of your quotes is when you're
winning you're not as good as you think
you are when you're losing you're not as
bad as you think you are what's that
mean to you both of them lie you know
both of them is exaggerated you know
both of them uh are when you when you're
winning everybody's telling you how
amazing you are oh my God let me tell
you dude you you know what you're the
best
you're amazing you know you're just
better than that guy and you're better
than this guy and it always takes me
back to that quote of Marcus aelius who
had a slave that would sit behind him
and always whisper to him hey you're
just a man you're just a man you're just
a man that's right 40 Laws of Power
right you're just a man you're just a
man you're just a man and then he would
get up and he became the best Emperor
what 6280 to 69 whatever the time is and
he becomes who he becomes and we read
about him now you know you pick up the
book meditations you're like this is
like mandatory reading for anybody what
is this all about right you know a
simple book not that big you can read it
in one hour no it's not it's not and
you're going through it saying what was
this about then you Google what did he
mean by this wow I didn't think about it
that way so and then when you're losing
everybody tells you I told you shouldn't
have done that I knew you wern't going
to make it yeah I I I told you it wasn't
for you you you weren't that guy and you
believe that as well so both of them are
are lying for me politically politically
I'm a capitalist hardcore capitalist I
fully am a capitalist to the core I
think the free market will create
solutions to problems I think the free
Market's going to filter out all the
fakers in uh Pharma in finance in
podcasting in sports in real estate in
insurance it takes two decades but it'll
filter people out it's not it's got zero
sympathy for you it doesn't care to be
friend you can give capitalism as many
compliments as you want he doesn't feel
it he has no emotions you can't flatter
capitalism all he's interested in is
results are you good enough can you ask
can you recreate yourself
great but when it comes on to politics I
want to hear both sides okay I'm a
Christian but I held a podcast four
weeks ago I brought two Muslims and I
brought two Christians and I had them go
at it for or two hours discussion
because my uh conversation was more
about okay if we agree on seven
different thing we disagree on seven
different things but you agree on 23
different things can we figure out a way
to make this work why do you feel the
way you do why do you feel the way you
do and they go back and forth and you're
s there saying okay interesting today
Israel Palestine with what's going on
with Hamas complicated lots of issues
you know on one end the question is
where pro-israel
where folks are going back and forth you
know I'm a pro-israel guy I'm from Iran
when I lived in Iran for 10 years Iran
was safer when Rea palavi was there
because they were strong and they had
allies with everybody and Israel was
safe the Middle East was saved you could
go and say you know what Patrick next
week you know where I'm going where are
you going I'm going to tan Iran because
Frank anatra is performing there I want
to do a podcast with Frank Sinatra I
said you're doing a podcast with Frank
Sinatra in Teran Iran sick you would
have been able to say that in 76 in 75
so the Middle East was fairly peaceful
not perfect but it was peaceful but at
the same time it you know you got to ask
the
question how did Israel with the best
intelligence mad not know that for one
year Hamas was training for this how did
you not know that they went and built a
city similar to the one that you haven't
trained on how to break into homes and
take hostages you didn't know that you
really didn't know that and intelligence
gave you report from here from Egypt but
you didn't know that it's a fair
question to ask but when he ask that
question guess what people say what kind
of a question is that this is not the
time to ask that question do you realize
what they're doing to kids I don't
support it I'm not supporting any of
that stuff then I got another question
because Palestinians said that's exactly
right this was intentional by Israel
they know what I ask Palestinians and
they also don't ask this question here's
a question if you're so peaceful who
knows more about Palestinians us who
live in America or UK or your neighbor
if you live in a condo or if you live in
a house and you've been living in this
house for 5 years or 10 years you have a
neighbor on this side you have a
neighbor on this side you know when they
do barbecues you know how much they
drink you know who which in-laws comes
in you know the son when he sneaks in
the girlfriend at 1:00 in the morning
you know the daughter when she sneaks
out and changes her skirt and gets into
a car with that bad boy and goes out and
does what she does and she comes back at
4:00 you know your neighbors you see all
their mess
okay if if
Palestine and Gaza is filled with so
many peaceful people why is Egypt not
taking them as refugees to go to Egypt
Egypt knows a lot about you why is it
only 800 people why are they not letting
a million people come to you so somebody
may say what a shameful question for you
to ask how dare you ask the question I
think both questions need to be asked
what you do with it is up to you okay so
for me this whole concept of when you're
winning don't believe the hype when
you're losing don't believe the hype
whatever story even your own side is
saying why don't you be skeptical a
little bit and question it for yourself
and see if you can entertain both ideas
I I want to find ways to entertain both
ideas as much as possible because I find
myself becoming sharper when I do that
and I eliminate blind spots anytime I'm
100% one side I have way too many blind
spots we'll get back to talking to
Patrick in minute but first I need to
tell you about Fountain life here's a
crazy statistic nearly 70% of heart
attacks occur without any prior symptoms
simply put the human body is really good
at hiding disease and this is where
Fountain life comes in they provide
top-of-the-line Health snapshots vetted
Therapeutics and a team of longevity
Physicians so that you can live a longer
healthier and more vital life in
seemingly healthy adults Fountain life's
initial results have shown 2% have
cancer 2 and a half% have a potential
ruptured aneurism looming in their
future and over 14% have a critical
life-saving finding right now you can
get the exact treatment that I got by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to fountainlife
docomond wisdom using the form on that
page to get
$500 off their Apex membership that's
fountainlife
tocom modern wisdom do you think that
we're obliged to have a take on
everything because I have
got involved in the Israel Palestine
conflict and there's a lot of people
that are very unhappy the silence is
violence crowd your silence is deafening
why haven't you come out in support or
against this group or that group is it
an obligation for us all to have a take
on everything if if the background has
to do anything with you I think you are
obligated to talk about it meaning if
you're a Jew I think you have to if
you're Palestinian you have to if you're
a Muslim I think you have to because
it's your community it's your pride it's
your
background if you're a political show
and you've spoken about Ukraine and
Russia and you've touched that topic why
are you not touching this topic now I
don't know if you have if your audience
no no no to all of the above then guess
what that means then you're consistent
so no you don't have to if you've been
consistent with all of it you don't have
to talk about it that's not what the
show is about you could simply say you
want to hear that show go to Ben Shapiro
well what people are saying they're not
saying why haven't you come in
specifically what they saying your
position is what they want what they're
saying is why haven't you said the thing
that supports the stance that I want you
to haven't you for each of them no why
have no listen why haven't I commented
on at all I mean listen there there's a
lot of events in the world that if you
and I had to comment on all of them we
don't have a life you would have to do
12-hour podcast to cover everything on a
daily basis
no but this is a once in 50 years type
of Crisis that could lead to a world War
I numbers came yesterday where Ray Dalo
I don't know if you've sat down with Ray
doio okay so you know who Ray doio is
he's a$2 billion man built an incredible
company I had them on as well Ray Doo
yesterday said the chance of World War
III is officially at 50% and Jamie
Diamond yesterday said these are the
most dangerous times we're living in
decades okay so one may say well you get
tens of millions of eyeballs you're no
longer somebody that gets back in the
days your first show when you did where
220 people watch it and Mom and Dad
didn't watch it your siblings didn't
watch it your best friends didn't watch
it no now you're getting well that's the
interesting question right whether
somebody with a sufficiently large
platform is obligated to comment on
things simply because they have a large
platform and you asked why whether I
have and why I haven't if I
haven't I found out about the incidents
that were going on in the Middle East on
Twitter two days after they happened and
I wondered why why hammers was trending
and I thought what the [__] hammers oh
[__] that's Hamas that was two days
after everything had happened by this
time I'd already had texts from people
saying dude like you going to get you
going to do an episode on this and I was
like bro the requisite amount of
understanding for me to be able to add
an educated opinion to this topic is not
one that I have time to do I mentioned
you earlier on we've been traveling we
were in La we were there for two days
all I did all I've done for the last
week is travel sleep research and record
and I've researched very specific guests
I haven't been researching stuff about
the Middle East right so that's all I've
had time to do is it not the precise
problem that people who do not know what
they're talking about have given Cod
psychology insights way outside of their
domain of expertise and just added to
the noise rather than adding to the
signal and yet there was a group of
people on the internet that would say no
but this is so important to me that it's
something that should move a aside the
other things that you're doing in life
and I think a final element of this is
people who are chronically
online cannot understand what it's like
to not be chronically online I am
chronically online for periods and then
I am chronically traveling around and
researching and recording and going from
hotel to hotel coming out to Florida
this is one of those periods during
which there's a lot of reading that
needs to be done to make a comment to
contribute to something that lots of
people who are better educated than me
can it's the same reason I didn't
comment on
co co was something that was happening
we did a couple of episodes explaining
how we felt people could better work
from home some mental health tools that
we thought that they could use uh some
strategies that they could do to uh
improve their time blocking and some
stuff like that here's how we would
design your homework station I'm like if
you want me to comment and just throw
horseshit at the wind I can do it but I
don't think that it's going to benefit
anything so yeah there's this
compulsion this obligation I think that
uh certain groups on the internet feel
anybody that comments on things should
get themselves involved with and uh it's
just are you surprised no not at all
because what they want but again they
don't want you to comment they want you
to support their side no that's a
different story that that that's a
different story there's a difference
between commenting and supporting right
I'm not if I comment I'm giving you my
thoughts and I'm going to share with you
my uh uh you know opinion thoughts on my
life experience on what I think is going
on and then from there agree or disagree
for the people who are asking you to
contribute if your thoughts and your
life experience LED you to uh implicate
one side rather than the other sound
like you were being more generous to one
side rather than the other they would
very quickly say I wanted you to comment
but I didn't want you to say that they
would very quickly have an issue with is
that your brand though is your brand uh
uh of of 700 episodes 25 200 Clips you
know is your brand given opinion on
current events have you done that in the
past because here's what happens so in
the market you know how in Hollywood
they say this guy's a triple threat
what's a triple threat act sing dance
okay in podcasting there's also triple
threats okay what's a triple threat a
great interview were which you are MH
but that's one of three two is
perspective and opinion which Joe Rogan
is people want to hear what Joe has to
say about this and then three is
entertain can you entertain me while
you're giving me your perspective or
asking questions where I'm kind of like
man I was funny as hell yeah so Joe the
reason why Joe is number one is because
Joe's great
host we want to hear his perspective
agree or disagree he has the he has the
conviction and the confidence to give
aside and be willing to change hey one
minute you're voting for Bernie Sanders
four years later you're saying to save
America you got to vote for Trump and
Republican what what are you talking
about right so then three is he
entertains you he makes you
laugh your
brand you have to take the risk whether
you want to go to two I don't think you
needs to comment on absolutely
everything if Joe was to be asked what
do you think of Aaron Rogers most recent
Achilles rupture as you said ear that's
not that's not a but there's a different
story with that you asked about
consistency earlier on Ukraine Russia
didn't comment on Co didn't comment on
then that's your brand then but but but
by the way what you just said is your
perspective absolutely but it's a meta
perspective on what's going on you're
not going to please everybody they look
I'm Armenian and ass Syrian okay so and
I was born in Iran so here's where I'm
screwed I'm half Armenian half Assyrian
born in Iran and I'm an American okay so
Horseman of the Apocalypse oh my God so
whenever something happens with Armenian
Genocide I have to within a second
comment on it okay and I do but not
within a second because I don't have
Intel so when you're talking about your
days what it looks like research all
that stuff you're telling the truth but
I'm running nine companies and I got a
wife and I got four kids and I'm
transitioning with another company and
I'm doing research on a podcast and I'm
doing the interviews and I'm running a
tech startup and I'm running a
consulting firm with clients that are
traveling worldwide to come to us and
I'm doing our our best to kind of see
what's going on with stories yeah
there's going to be days you just don't
have time and the audience can
understand and cannot understand it
right that's a decision they got to make
uh so Assyrians hey did you see what
happened at that theater when are you
going to come in at this wedding that
just took place and 100 people were dead
and a place caught on fire and these
people okay great let me get some Intel
and then I'll comment on it and then I
did you know or Iran or you know
but but the natural part where I would
take it as a compliment is the audience
is leaning on you to see how you would
assess this issue and they trust the way
you reason and nowadays there's not
enough people who are able to reason to
give a different perspective because
they simply don't trust mainstream media
but then the next step is do you want to
take the risk of going in that side if
your brand is not on Co not on uh
Ukraine not on this then you're stay in
consistent I think largely the main
lesson I learned I learned this from
Douglas Murray is that there are a lot
of people in the online space who do not
have expertise within a particular
domain and have it in another one they
have expertise within psychology or
climate change or whatever it might be
and then they start thinking to
themselves
well why why shouldn't my thoughts on
the Ukraine be important to people what
everybody thinks that my insights about
climate change are are absolutely
wonderful and they start
their if you want to mys of competence
I'll comment on it for me there are
people out there who are capable
prepared to do the work have the time
and have the expertise I don't think
that the internet needs more noise I
think it needs more signal and I would
be contributing nothing short of noise
if I did that I'm also just not
passionate about learning about this
topic and I understand that in order for
me to give
the for me to meet the bar of evidence
and insight that I would want to to feel
proud about my opinion I need to be
passionate about it right I need to be
compelled to Lear are you passionate
about life of course I am would you like
to live to 200 years old yes okay so do
many of your listeners because the
feedback you give has to do with living
a great life because people are watching
the life you're living the only thing I
would encourage you to consider from the
audience side is this is a different
crisis this Cris is if reasonable people
like you can find a way to lower the
overreaction that people are having with
everything that's out there I would say
you would actually contribute to
lowering the overreaction community so
I'm I'm simply complimenting you to
consider the fact that people are
looking to see how a reasonable person
like you that can give a logical
perspective because that's what's
missing today and when when a ray Doo
when a Jamie Diamond when many of these
guys are saying
50% and you with your millions of people
who listen to you can and it's not a
niche audience where it's in one country
or two countries your audience is
worldwide 100 plus countries you got
people listening to you I think maybe
from that level the feedback from the
audience could be this is not a regular
issue we' like to hear your thoughts and
then whether you choose to do it or not
it's your prerogative and we move on
yeah you've got a
you mentioned there about this sort of
loss of faith in our institutions right
the previous Gatekeepers the people that
we would have relied on to tell us
what's what in the
world what do you think about this
Rising
skepticism uh there is also a degree of
conspiratorial thinking uh heterodox
cynicism around what we're being told is
this leaving a vacuum where people's
uncertainty is making their lives worse
what is is going to happen from a a
sense making how do people make sense of
the world when we can't trust the
information
communicators well that's that's why
they want to hear from you so so what
you're saying is is validating their
point so in America today we are at the
lowest levels we've ever been for
Americans trusting mainstream media and
trusting the government not one or the
other the lowest in both we don't trust
the government we don't trust mainstream
media the last time the the people Trust
Tred mainstream media and the government
the highest was right before Kennedy
died after that that was at 72% it's
gone from 72 65 60 down to today 27%
people simply don't trust the mainstream
media to give feedback on what's really
taking place there's a reason why Rogan
gets more eyeballs on his show than all
these guys combined and people are
watching to see what he has to say
there's a reason why Shapiro gets the
eyeballs he gets there's a reason why
you get the eyeballs there's reason why
all these other guys get the eyeballs is
because they want to hear a different
perspective you know we're going back to
the the the story where you know and
this quote's been criticized many times
it's not really true you know amateurs
buil you know professionals built the
Titanic amateurs built the arc you know
this whole story that they go back and
forth professionals run mainstream media
amateurs run podcasting but the world is
trusting amateurs running podcasting
more than the people that build the
Titanic because a lot of people think
mainstream media is about to sink like
the Titanic dick now whether it did or
not who knows but people want to talk to
somebody that's just a regular guy says
y what's your story what do you think
about this what are your thoughts on
this do you really agree do I does
anybody else feel I kind of feel that
way as well I'm a little bit skeptical
I'm a little bit worried about this
what's going on is it really as big as
they make it out to be should I trust
these guys so I'm not surprised this is
taking place by the way you know what's
the only thing that's keeping mainstream
media in business it's only a couple
things that keeping mainstream media in
business number one
is 75 year olds 70 75 year olds are
keeping mainstream media in business
okay so that's another 10 to 15 years
before that generation is no longer here
that audience is gone number two is Big
Pharma if two countries in the world
that allow big Pharma companies to
advertise it's us and New Zealand every
other country in the world you cannot
advertise the only two countries in the
world where pharmaceutical companies
like fiser that can advertise is us and
New Zealand everywhere else there is no
commercials on TV do you realize what
would happen if a
president did an executive order got
Congress everybody in it to say moving
forward big Pharma can no longer
advertise on mainstream media you know
what happens the next day every one of
them goes out of business and all these
talented guys at ESPN or at CNN or fox
or ABC that are getting the 515 $20
million
contract gone 80% of Revenue who's gone
and a lot of these guys now have to go
and try to make it in the world that
you're making it and this is hard what
you're doing is hard there's not a
teleprompter behind me there's nobody
whispering in your ears what to say
follow up with this question this is all
you doing it right to them hey ask him
this follow up with this we just found
data 63% he's lying follow this you
watch did you watch any of the late
night hosts when they tried to do a
podcast between them yes what did you
think from a professional's perspect a
amateur professional's perspective
there's a reason why they can't do
anything without writers you know I mean
don't get me wrong to me Fallon is a
very talented guy a very talented guy uh
and you're not going to get to that job
without having talent these guys got a
lot of talent they're workers but the
moment writers are done you mean to tell
me from May 12th you guys can't do an
episode until what October which they
just started with two weeks ago you
realize writers control this world now
the writers are worried that Chad gbt
can write the jokes of what's going on
and what if AI and pop out these you
know jokes and what could take place no
this game is a very very hard game this
is not an easy game think about what
Spotify did what other president in the
last 20 years has been as popular as
Obama and let me get this straight Obama
and another guy named Bruce Springsteen
start a podcast and Spotify drops him
what who else has been more popular in
the last 20 years on television than Kim
Kardashian with 300 million followers on
in Instagram Spotify signs a podcast
with her then they drop her what who
else has been more on TV and every
magazine newspaper than Harry and Megan
but Spotify dropped their podcast and
hasn't fully is like we're not renewing
the contract and then they give Rogan a
few hundred wait what so let me get the
straight just being famous doesn't help
to have a podcast no wow I thought it
was just about Fame no this is hard this
is an art this is very difficult to do
it's not easy to do so if mainstream
media sinks like the Titanic 90% of that
Talent is going to disappear and they're
not going to know what to do 90% of them
it's not any game there's does this mean
or does this contribute
to complicity or those commentators and
all of the other people whose wages
ultimately are paid for by those
adverts does this does this create a uh
perverse incentive for them in what way
that they may
be prepared to compromise something they
truly think to not jeopardize the people
that ultimately pay their
wages that there is a risk to them
saying something out of turn which may I
mean are you really asking that question
or you know the answer to that question
you already know the answer you're a
smart guy yeah no of course they they
they have to they don't have a choice to
take that position right I'll give you
an idea Chris CUO was on CNN for God
knows how many years and he was a number
one guy for two or three years what does
CNN do to Chris fired his brother Andrew
Kom Governor fired and then he's got
$125 million pending lawsuit against CNN
and now CNN folks can't talk to Chris I
had him on the podcast and for the
longest time CUA was hated by a lot of
people on the right absolutely hated
because the stuff you would say where is
Jesus is Jesus going to come and save
you with with Co what's Jesus going to
do for you and all this stuff he would
say right well he came on a podcast and
I'm with one of my partners in Dallas
he's a billionaire himself in the
insurance SP he's the number one power
player in Insurance we're at his uh uh
office corner office in the top one of
the sickest offices you'll see in your
life like 60th floor he's overlooking
all of Dallas Brian and he
says you know it's kind of weird
watching CUA on your podcast I said why
he says he sounded different you know
there was moments where I I kind of
liked him when I was watching this and
this is not a guy I can say something
like that with you know how many people
said that what happened to him he's now
a free agent he's got a shirt he sells
that's called free agent he's got a
podcast that says you know uh uh you
know with something quo project that
he's got a podcast and how does he dress
like
you we with him a couple weeks ago in in
uh what do you call it in um uh Sag
Harbor in U up in uh that entire area
whatever that area is I forget the name
uh sagap ponic Sag Harbor all that stuff
and we go to his house my kids are
running around the back he say hey Pat
somebody wants to talk to you I said
who's that FaceTime he goes like this
like oh [__] what's up Robert Downey Jr
how you doing so I'm having a
conversation with him but forget about
talking to Robert Downey Jr I wanted to
see my kids' reaction especially my two
boys cuz my boys went
died my kids were devastated when he
dies Iron Man dies in you know in the do
you know what today is the Marvel
Cinematic Universe today is the
canonical death day of Tony Stark when
he clicks his fingers today is the day
the date get out of here today is the
date I did not know that what is the
chance of me bringing up the story and I
don't even know that story so I said
Dylan Tio come here said daddy we're
running around with the dogs I said
trust me come here
and Chris turns the camera around he
goes like this my son goes oh my God Z
man I know you and then the other son
Tio his reaction Dylan's reaction you
know you love Robert downe he's one of
those guys that you absolutely love when
you go back to his journey I was talking
about the movie that my dad and I
watched 30 years ago only you and the
only movie I've ever watched four hours
two hours two back toback in a row was
Judge it's by Robert Downey Jr what's
the moral of the story The Moment Chris
Koma was free
and he didn't give a
[__] he just kind of told you what he
was kind of going through would you like
it or not you may not agree with
everything but he's finally free a lot
of these guys working on mainstream
media they're not free and we now see
tuck his transition and guess what he's
killing it okay love him or hate him
when Tucker puts on a show everybody's
watching what this guy's got to say so I
found out from the guys that light and
Tech all of this stuff that we're doing
here who understand very very very
closely what's going on Bennett was it
anamorphic lenses is that what they shot
Tucker's first thing in his garage
with yeah so anamorphic lens is a very
particular type of lens very particular
type of shooting very uh short wide so
it has the image of I maybe it was his
garage or something like that or a
living room with the background behind
him make no mistake that is lit and shot
in cinema quality right with the facade
of it being a a sort of lowbudget thing
right so it's this this on an iPhone
yeah precisely it's this beautiful
blending of both and uh that's exciting
I think it's exciting to see what these
guys do and also you know I love this
about given that we spend so much time
talking and and people have this uh
concern about whether or not someone's
gaming the system are they trying to
growth hack relatability right or
authenticity seeing I would be lying if
I said that I didn't take an amount of
pleasure to see late night hosts that
have got massive platforms struggle to
hold a conversation together for an hour
over Zoom because that is ultimately the
battle place of ideas right it's not how
well can you read a script from a
teleprompter I mean there is skill
absolutely skill in being able to do
that and I couldn't I couldn't do the
writing I couldn't do the performance I
couldn't do the bits and the blah blah
the
music but largely you are a marionette
right that's being ventriloquized by a
handful of writers and and
xxs ultimately seeing what you can do
when the gloves are off is more
interesting to me this is very hard this
is this is very hard because how long is
your average podcast hour and a half
okay so an hour and a half of keeping
people's interests with no breaks and
nobody talking to you and touching up
the makeup to them what are you talking
about that is absolutely in insane to do
something like that no this is very hard
and the market has proven that this
isn't for everybody the market is proven
you cannot keep my attention for that
long this is very very difficult when
when people started saying I remember I
hired a u a marketing expert you know 13
years ago 14 years ago he came in and
said well Studies have shown you're
making one of the mistakes you're making
on YouTube your videos are about 12
minutes long and the only videos that do
well is 12 minutes after 12 minutes out
I said n man I'm doing 42 minutes 28
minutes hour and 20 minutes that's a
mistake number one thing we have to do
is no video can go past 13 minutes like
dude okay maybe this guy's the expert he
sold this company for a couple million
you know what happened the day we fired
him 60 days later our first video goes
viral and gets 40 million views today
it's got a half a billion views okay for
the life of an entrepreneur 902 takes
off right and we start making other
clips and other videos and other stuff
and you see Joe takes it to a whole
different level three hours and you got
Lex Freedman takes it to all different
level 4 hours 3 hours and 48 minutes you
know yeah what Lex does he did seven
hours with
BAGI guys are glutton for
punishment yeah you um you tweeted
something that I thought was quite
interesting you said why do so many
people who come to the America from
other countries with little to no money
at all within 10 years outpace the
average person who was born
here what is going
on where Americans who have all of the
I'm an immigrant to this country
right many people who are given from the
very beginning all of the benefits of
being from this country why is it that
they are outpaced by people who weren't
born
here so six seven months ago I'm sitting
with my state planner and one of the
fears I have for the last 10 years is
what I'm going to do with my kids with
the wealth with money am I raising them
in a way that they're not going to turn
out being the you know the snobby
arrogant kid that you know Silver Spoon
oh man I cannot I never like those kids
in school those are the kids I got into
fights with I never like those kids so I
don't want to raise those types of kids
and then you go and read these books
about which families generationally
created a wealth that stayed like
Vanderbilt raised a bunch of snaps so
Vanderbilt's money only lasted one
Generation generation later there's no
money left so when you read the story
about that Anderson Cooper's a
Vanderbilt but his mother said even
though we were Vanderbilt don't expect
any kind of trust fund baby you ain't
got no money here nothing's coming over
you got to make your own money you know
and but you look at the medich family on
what they did five six seven generation
what did they do differently you look at
Rockefeller still has the money you look
at some of these other families that
kept the money within the family what
did they do what did they structure and
there's State planning where you can go
to you know 10 15 20 $50,000 then
there's guys you can hire that's a
100,000 quarter million a million
dollars but those estate planners when
you hire you know what they do they
interview your kids so they go sit down
with your kids and after they talk to
you and they'll say how do you want to
set this up for the money with your kids
who gets money what do they need to do
what's the criteria are you okay if to
get this what kind of cars do you not
want them to buy to waste the money who
do you want them to work for what
happens with this business can they lose
all the money are you given equally
here's what this family and they give
you all these suggestions on how to prop
properly set it up once you and your
wife agree on what you want to do with
that wealth these guys have meetings
with all your kids without you there and
they'll record it so you can see how the
meeting went went but they're setting it
up with them so they'll say Okay kids
this is U on behalf of your parents
here's a few things you need to know
number one um the good news is your
parents are very prepared on what
they've done with you and here's what
you can get your parents have worked
very hard and they have made a lot of
money and if you do it right some of
that can be passed over to you but if
you don't you're not going to get get it
either let me go through some of these
criterias
da these three things you do you're not
going to get anything these two things
you do if you do this here's what's
going to happen this is what they want
us to use the money with and then they
kind of break it down to them now you
know how many families actually do that
very few those conversations most people
don't have most people are so much about
go go go go go go go and then you die
unexpectedly oh we didn't set up the
state planning let alone the detail the
state planning know okay now your kids
are spoiled rot and doing what they're
doing had this conversation with a
number of friends uh Ben Francis who is
the CEO of jym shark his net worth is
triple Drakes um he's a St of a guy by
the way Ser the podcast a couple years
ago St serious dude uh I was talking to
him and I think that it's the same with
you one of the things that you value the
most in your upbringing have been the
hard times the spit and sord dust uh
lessons and rules the Harden the School
of Hard Knocks right it's given you the
work rate that has permitted you to be
able to achieve the success that you
have and
reverse locally reverse entropy right so
you've been able to Wrangle your reality
in a way that you want it
to and yet you have worked so hard to be
able to give your kids opportunities
that you never had MH and yet you know
that they need to go through the
hardships and that those are where the
lessons I learned are going to prepare
them this to me seems like a very uh
interesting tension right I want to give
my kids opportunities that I've worked
so hard for if I don't what the [__] was
the point in me working so hard and yet
they need to go through the difficulty
they need to do how have you found this
tension between the two well that's a
great question but I want to finalize by
making a point when you asked the
question about why is it that so many
people come to America within 10 years
they have more money than the people
that were born in America because
unfortunately the way we've ran America
if the American Born kids
are kids of these families they're the
kids of the families that spoiled them
in
America there's no more earning things
in America just handed out to them we're
printing money left and right we're
giving away income to people left and
right we're making life easier we're
incentivizing the wrong things do you
know in 1940 in America what percentage
of kids were born to single mothers in
1940 in America what percentage of kids
were born to a single mother who's not
married with no father in the household
4% is the number did you know the number
or no it's 4% you know what that number
is today over 50 it's over 40% Shia 50%
you're right there at the number you
mean to tell me we went from
1944% to today so what happened there
first of all policies by FDR Social
Security and incentives of taking care
of single mothers then Lyndon Johnson in
1965 took it to a whole different level
mothers are sitting there saying the
more kids I have the more entitled
programs I get great great why would I
get married if I get married I lose
those benefits the incentive programs
America set up totally screwed
everything up it incentivized the bad
behavior it's like telling a kid can you
imagine if you're in estate planning you
say for every kid you have not married
I'll pay you
$700 whose fault is that parents fault
bad policies have consequences yeah you
create a bad policies what person in the
right State of Mind when they have their
wealth America is a family it's a
corporation what person in the right
mind would incentivize what parents
would incentivize kids to say I want to
have more kids and I'm going to give you
money out of the living trust nobody in
the right mind would do that but America
did so what happened to us now we got
all this crime now we're paying the
price for it because all these years
there's no father in there to put them
in their place to challenge them to
straighten them up that's not in place
you know so that is a missing piece that
these kids don't have in America so to
me if we looked at America America as a
family as a corporation estate planning
matters you know living trust matters
the right policies matters listen I even
think to the point where you know how in
America voting starts at 18 years
old I would much rather this is a very
uh strange policy I'm going to share
with you when I posted this on on
YouTube a lot of people very upset with
me I would much rather have somebody
who's 14 and a half years old who's had
a job and paid $1,000 in taxes vote than
a 28y old kid who's never had a job
never pay taxes I don't want that guy to
vote why because he contributed to
society the 14 and a halfy old kid the
15-year-old kid contributed to society
and realize how hard it is to pay the
taxes into whatever they're spending
money on you want to spend $100 billion
to Ukraine we could have buil 20 walls
we could have build 20 walls with that
money that was sent you're not saying
Ukraine I'm saying it so you're safe
don't worry they're not they're not
going to come after you they're going to
come after me so all of these things
that you look at were going away from
earning when a immigrant comes here all
they're looking at saying wait a minute
I can go work this and do this do this
and do this and I'm gonna earn this yes
I'm going I'm going town all day I'm
good with this many Americans don't have
that mindset because bad policies have
consequence that we're suffering uh uh
the negative impact of that but you as a
follow-up question right with kids and
your question is how to balance it with
challenging them yet still having the
opportunity what was the question you
were asking yeah the tension between you
affording your kids the benefits that
all of your hard workers allowed them to
do and so I'm greedy I'm very greedy and
here's what I mean by I'm very greedy I
want my kids as close to me for the rest
of my life we have a family that lives
in our community uh Messi just bought a
house right next to our house and he
just moved into the community he caused
a lot of Mayhem it's all over the place
cops are coming in every week we have
you know what do you call it Paparazzi
craziness that's going on but one of the
families that lives in our community
they they run a medical company with six
7,000 employees so the the founders the
mom and dad their houses here right next
door to the house they have two sons the
other son lives here who's the chief
marketing officer their oldest son's
house is here each son has four kids
each son has four kids both sons are
doctors both sons married someone who's
a doctor and they each have four kids
they have a structure on what they do
Monday nights every Tuesday night they
have dinner together and they talk about
God every wednes there's a system yeah
to everything they do he'll call me and
say hey we went fishing this morning I
got a bunch of fish can I drop it off to
you I am enamored by how those parents
created that kind of a structure where
their kids are respectful their
grandkids are respectful we're going to
Halloween we're walking in Halloween
doing trick-or treating and
the son comes by 17-year old son comes
by and he says yeah he doesn't have his
uh iPhone with him I said how does he
not not not have his iPhone with him he
says in our family standards very easy
you want your phone you got to have
straight A's he's got to B I said well
let me get this straight your
17-year-old son doesn't have a phone
because he doesn't have one because he
has one be he says yeah it's our
standard I said what are you talking
about it's very simple you just got to
make sure you got straight A you get a
phone you get the car you get this now
some somebody's going to listen to this
and say what what a freaking extreme set
of Standards that's tyranny that's
tyranny that's exactly the type of kids
that end up becoming D no problem it's
called standards and expectations and
for a family who has the ability to use
money and waste it and do whatever they
want to keep that kind of Standards I
respect that even more and guess what
the son loves his father loves his
mother loves her grandparents respectful
kids so it's it's not easy to do but if
it matters to you eventually a my life
when I say I'm greedy I would love to
create a proposition for my kids were 20
years from now they want to run one of
the companies they want to be within the
company they want to work with within
one of the companies and i' like him to
live close to me will it happen it's
going to take us 30 years to find out
because dude pan generational housing
I'm seeing in Austin right commune a
ranch where someone's buying up a ton of
land and then there there's another one
of those puppies down there if you want
it uh they're buying up a ton of land
and we're going to not just have us
we're going to have somebody else come
and live with us as well we're going to
have Grandma and Grandpa and they're
going to be that this is the way that it
was this is the way that it was and
here's another thing to consider right
would you rather have drinking two going
to do anything to me or no what's you're
going to survive you're going to be
dialed in you're going to survive I
promise whatever whatever the internet
throws at you you'll survive so what is
the
uh yeah so we've got that's Citrus that
one's orange one sunit okay interesting
wild citus
so one of the interesting questions that
you have here would
be would you rather have a parent who
pities you more than they believe in
you you didn't do well it's okay that
teacher doesn't understand let me Pat
you on the back come here little Timmy
will take you for ice cream or would you
rather have a parent who says I believe
in you more than more than I pity
you I mean look I'll tell you my dad
very annoying man okay because
never sympathized never felt sorry for
anything never it was always standards
an expectation but he always loved me so
when I was 6 years old and my teacher
asked me what do you want to be when you
grow up I said I want to be a father why
I said because I want to be like my dad
I had a very good dad my dad's still
with us he was in the hospital this week
but he's out he's doing good he's at the
house kids love him everybody loves him
my kids all have a relationship with him
he's 81 years
old it took a lot to please my dad my
dad wasn't impressed by anything he
wouldn't be be there and say oh my gosh
and by the way he's a middle eastern uh
Father which means I've never played
catch with the guy we've never thrown
the football we never played anything no
Sports he just he was a worker since 8th
grade he dropped out in Iran and he
started working to take care of his mom
and dad their family was very very close
you know but again remember how earlier
on when we're talking about you know
choosing your enemies wisely we talked
about how the the top performers have a
person that gave them uncondition
love and one that brought a lot of pain
and then they chose their enemies wisely
I
think the role of a person that is
gentle and another one that nothing's
ever good enough is a great combination
I think if both parents are gentle
that's a problem and I also think if
both parents are nothing's ever good
enough is also a problem yeah I think
you need a little bit there's a reason
why the Creator God created the Dynamics
that he created you know I have a one of
our guys were spending our photographers
with us and he's holding his daughter
while we're doing a photo shoot this
Saturday and she keeps asking for Mom
she keeps asking say is she is she
Daddy's girl M I say no it's all mommy I
said when does she want you whenever
she's scared she comes to
me so the kid runs to Daddy when she's
scared but goes to Mommy when she's hurt
that's an interesting Dynamic how it is
she feels
safer by Dad when there's a risk but
feel safer by mom when she's hurt
because she's going to be pampered and
taken care of yeah I think that's very
healthy combination there was a
quarterback Brett F many years ago I
don't know if you know Brett far he's a
famous texter that's an inside joke if
you know who he is but
uh um he has his quarterback he has his
coach so tough on him so tough on him
nothing was ever good with this
quarterback kicking his ass talking [__]
to him in the sideline how could you
throw that interception what the [__]
was that all about what was that all
about and he's afraid of the coach and
he's always escaping the coach but there
was a guy that was I think his name was
maruchi Steve maruchi and he would
always put his arm around him listen he
believes in you once you prove him right
deep down inside he believes in you go
through the P that you know he he knows
he can throw show him exactly what we
got let's go win this game for him let's
get so that Dynamic worked incredibly
well for Brett fart as well as many
other players out there so I think you
know one without the other is a problem
if you got both it's a great combination
yeah there's a lot of problems with
fatherlessness in homes uh Melissa Cary
just wrote a new book called the two
parent Advantage uh two parent privilege
sorry and uh dude it's terrifying just
the raw data the raw outcomes that you
get your mom and dad stayed together yes
okay married till today yep only child
so only child only child do you have the
only child uh syndrome yes what do you
mean the guy that's the center of all of
these lights and stuff in some regards
okay in some regards yes but I think I
had quite a Stern upbringing I was held
to incredibly high standards uh was very
non- rebellious as a kid um non-
rebellious very non- rebellious very
very non- rebellious um you know wasn't
going out wasn't sneaking out I don't
think I ever got grounded once the god
play a role or no no standards and
expectation was it tough standards High
very high what did your mom and dad do
uh dad is an engineer mom stopped
working for probably 10 to 12 years to
raise me while Dad was out working uh
but this isn't you know Dad was on the
working class of most working class we
live in a a city in the UK that was
famous only for having the highest teen
pregnancy rating in the UK and then it
lost that so it didn't even have that as
a as a title anymore at least you could
brag about it now we got nothing exactly
we haven't even got that uh so but it
was it was very formative and you know
I'm just thinking more and more about
this tension between success making
people soft uh I spoke to David Goggins
about it on the podcast you know he's
this guy who can command millions of
dollars for speaking gigs and he's
choosing to go smoke jumping have you
seen this thing that he's doing so smoke
jumping is when there's a wildfire in
the middle of nowhere and they need to
air drop in the firefighters so they
parachute in with a a a pack around
their waist with all their stuff on and
they also put water huge
uh water bucket things that they'll
attach their hoses to separately
parachute them in and they just live in
the fire until they put it out sometimes
they're out there for a week pretty sure
he makes it's either s or $12 an hour
that he makes for doing this smoke
jumping as it's called it's in Canada
for the most part instead of going and
doing this speaking tour and I asked him
about success making you soft he says I
see it way too much and that's why I I
don't like it I'm not about the flash
I'm not about any of that one of the
best books in business was written by a
legend C legendary CEO in Silicon Valley
who ran Intel I think he's the only guy
that for a decade straight he grew the
company 100% every year unheard of what
this guy did Andy Grove Hungarian guy
okay you know what the book's title is
only the paranoids survive only the
paranoid survive heard you say that
before so I had a question to you around
only the paranoid
survive I don't disagree that paranoia
is an unbelievable competitive Advantage
it's a very useful performance enhancer
right you are paying more attention you
are more detail oriented you're more
fearful all the rest of it ultimately is
it worth it do you think is paranoia
worth it as a life strategy it the the
you are protected by those who take that
seriously okay you know burden is not
something that's a sexy sell you know
there there's a lot of things that you
and I can sell that's very sexy okay
work from home very sexy yet the
loneliness epidemic in America right now
is record-breaking numbers we've never
seen before right on what people are
doing how lonely they are numbers on
depression is off the charts right now
compared to what it was just 10 years
ago so yeah you can sell work from home
you can sell three and a half day work
week you can sell laptop entrepreneur
you can sell all these are all sexy
things to sell right you can sell set up
a funnel and make 20 grand a month and
don't have to do anything these are all
very interesting easy things to sell try
selling burden go ahead and sell burden
oh the the the incredible honor of
having burden of the responsibility of a
Nation or state or a military or
Freedom try selling it it's no it's not
an easy sale it's a hard sale
responsibility isn't sexy so why are so
many great leaders turned on by that
burden why why cuz someone's got to do
it so it all depends you know in the in
the book your next five moves I talk
about how the most important question
you got to answer in life is who do you
want to be what type of Life do you want
to live that's simple okay so what does
this mean do you want to be a Founder
yeah you
sure yeah positive I think so it's kind
of cool right wan to be a Founder
entrepreneur you sure you want to be a
Founder you sure you want to be the
number one guy Tom ellwart who is my
business partner said the best things to
me this guy was at the talk about the
legendary interview of all time it's the
last interview of Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates in Silicon Valley okay wherever it
was 300 people were invited at this
meeting Tom was one of them record it's
record you got to see it by the way sick
it's the red shair when you see the red
shair you're watching the right one
Steve Jobs is super skinny Tom ellswood
tells me says Pat it took me 50 years to
realize I don't make a lot of money when
I'm the number one guy the most money I
ever made is when I was number two
through number six
think about saying that think about
taking 52 years to realize 50 years to
realize the most money you ever made was
when you were the number two guy or
number six guy because there's burden
with number one number one has got to
sell the dream number one is got to sell
the vision number one has got to seem
like even though we're about to go out
of business they're at peace they're
calm they carry the burden sleepless
nights your finances you can't reveal to
people if you're about to run out of
money we're going to make the expenses
we're going to make salaries we're going
to pay
payroll that's the number one who wants
that burden nobody wants that burden so
no if the idea is to sell that no it is
not an easy sale but if you want to know
why you right now are here and we are
able to do this podcast at a pretty
unstable time in the world today it's
probably because around 500 people have
the burden of making sure Nobody messes
with you and I where we are are right
now and those 500 people have a th000
people underneath them or 500 people
underneath them why you and I are able
to sit here so it's not the most sexy
attractive thing like in in Smithsonian
I don't know if you've been to the
Smithsonian in DC there's a part where
you go and it shows you Walk This Way it
shows how Lincoln aged over it's an
incredible thing to see and there's a
quote there by by Lincoln about burden
okay the the being a president is the
greatest burden a a person can ever have
right some some quote like that I'm
paraphrasing so it's not for everybody
and it's not a cell the person chooses
to do it Obama before and after his
eight years right he still looks good
though he still got he's still got
Swagger but I mean that was 20 years in
eight years that's right so this is
something I wanted to talk about you
have spent a lot of time reading about
and researching and speaking to powerful
people who do you think really runs the
world you're going to go there huh with
the question who do I think runs the
world
um so I used to ask the question I said
who who's got the most power in America
is it Congress is it president is it the
cosos of virtual governments we're
talking Google Twitter Facebook you know
those guys Amazon you know or is it
billionaires okay you know the most
richest man in the world who's got the
most power and you'd be amazed how few
people say president cuz they come and
go you know the famous quote with Putin
that he says you know American
Presidents you don't have to worry about
it they're going to be there 4 to8 years
some suits are running you know run the
country behind closed doors and he's got
a very good point when he says something
like that Putin but to me there are a
lot
of alliances being built so if you and I
were to think about aspirational type of
people okay you know how they say you
know well Michael Jackson eventually got
to a point where we got so many
different girls that he started trying
with this and he started trying with
this and a lot of these people in
Hollywood have have so much sex with so
many different people that they become
creative and they do dumb things right
okay Tiger Woods the reason why he got
these girls because what do you know
what it is to be the greatest gol golfer
in the world and everybody throws their
panties at you you want to judge a guy
like that why don't you go be the
greatest golfer and see what it feels
like to be one out of eight billion you
don't know what it's like so they're
kind of trying and experimenting with
all this stuff right it's almost like
I'm so much in a prison jail everybody's
watching what I'm doing I Want to Break
The Rules a little bit to see what I'm
capable of doing okay so so let's go
process and dissect some of these guys
that make all the money the world okay
you become a
billionaire and you're still dangerously
ambitious not from a good place but more
selfish
place okay you took over an industry now
you're worth $5 billion now you're worth
10 if you're a billionaire you're the
best at what you do in your space for
the most part or you help build the best
in that space for the most part Okay
cool
so maybe your marriage didn't work out
maybe you're not the best father in the
world and you're like
well I want more control I want more
power I can't be a president I don't
want to be a president because if I run
for president they're going to reveal
the things that I've done in my life and
God forbid if that gets all the light I
don't want that that's embarrassing but
you know what I'm going to do what if I
can take over the
world are there other people like me
that are driven by wanting to take over
the world what if we could make the
world one place and we make all the
decisions for everybody because I'm
probably one of the smartest people in
the world I'm prob and you know that
conversation's taking place again you
really start having that Godlike figure
like I don't know if you're familiar
with George Soros you know in one of the
interviews he gave to LA Times he says I
always fancied myself with being a
god fancied myself with being a god this
is an LA Times interview 20 plus years
ago if you type in George Soros LA Times
God it's the the most disturbing
interview to read about this guy a lot
of people are very skeptical about him
right he's like the boogeyman of a
number of conspiracies how many how many
people have you heard say I always
fancied myself with being a God he says
but what's great about where I'm at
right now is it's no longer a dream F
became a reality yeah I have a friend
who has spent a lot of time with super
super powerful people and he told me
about a meeting that he had with one
individual in particular who spoke about
being an apex predator he said that apex
predators don't care about prey and even
though the prey that he was referring to
was still his own
species it was really haunting the story
the way that that was told to me because
you had someone who not only had the
motivation to be able to go and enact
whatever nefarious malicious plan but
also had the actual resources to be able
to go and do it right those two things
together are they're scary and that was
something that really opened my eyes I'm
very non-c conspiratorial in the way
that I think I I always lean toward you
know do not attribute to malice that
which can be explained by stupidity do
not attribute to coordination that which
can be explained by coincidence uh and
yet the more that I read and the more
that I learn about things the more there
there seems to be there
right yeah you know people are offended
by different
things
[Music]
um some
people being
offended in their deepest
insecurities they're willing to use
their Ambitions to go to certain levels
that at that point they're not thinking
about the consequen of ruining a lot of
people's lives that's not something
they're thinking about at that level so
Hitler was offended when you read MC for
you study what Hitler he was simply
offended somebody offended him so his
entire life was about doing what he did
just because he was offended now most
people who are offended they do what
they forget about it and they move on
some of these guys want control some of
these guys want to make decisions for
you some of these guys on the money side
at least they go and make money to get
power some people don't go make money to
get power some people CLA Schwab they're
like no I'm not going to go make money
to get power I'm going to get power by
creating laws and thinking I know what's
best for you so there's a lot of
different people that you can put in
these types of organization you just
have to think like if you were to think
about the commission of the mop always
go back to it lucky luchano created a
commission where the five families he
was the one that ran the commission
right of the five families okay when you
think about what meetings in the world
happens where all the powerful people
show up you got the G20 you got the UN
you got the world econom you got Davos
you got all these guys that come
together you got NATO you got that so
NATO could be like well NATO's original
when the 12 or 14 countries were part of
NATO what was it really all about to
fight USSR there is no USSR why are we
still funding it what's the outcome now
are we still fighting communism so what
a lot of people might say is that those
organizations are so obvious that they
can't be the ones where the real shit's
happening right that's just the smoke
screen the real [__] is the [__] that's
behind it and the [__] that's behind
that and so on and so forth in your
opinion do you think that NATO w F wh
That's those people there's no further
upet of strings that are playing the
Ventrilo quise game behind those ones do
you think that that's where a lot of
power actually
lies um I don't know what I will say
listening to you is with the questions
you're asking I think there's a reason
why the audience wants to hear what you
think about what's going on right now
because you're asking some heavy
questions right now which means you're
curious and if I'm the audience I would
like to know what you can come up with
if you took a deeper dive and really
wanted to get into these types of you
know informations but you
know think about what things people are
most addicted to okay addicted
personalities video games porn sex
cocaine ecstasy
weed steroids
partan all of that stuff but what's one
of the most addicting things that many
of those guys can't get power are you
kidding me power is like power porn the
porn of having a lot of power and
getting to look in people that look at
you that are afraid of you some people
love that some people love that you know
the quote like if you really want to
test someone's character give him power
I mean some people really love having
power take a company and see some of the
guys that they hired they hir the wrong
person at the top the gu gu was all
driven by power what happens take a
president that becomes a president and
he realizes he can use the justice
system against his opponent what happens
they got that power it's a lot of power
to give to somebody right um yeah so you
know those people I believe are out
there some of them are 100% money people
because money talks and you can have a
lot of need funds to do anything right
you do it's it's going to be the money
people um but there's also the other
Power Players behind closed doors that
you know in the in the movie
Moneyball uh Jonah Hill plays I don't
know if I'm saying his name correctly he
plays the role of the guy that Brad
poner saying why is this GM of Cleveland
Indians keeps looking at that
guy doesn't get on Bas who the hell are
you right in in John John Maxwell or or
or Bale Carnegie wrote about this in a
book saying the law of EF Hutton EF
Hutton was in the room that every time
the guy was making a decision he he
would have make a decision until he
asked about EF Hutton so so here's what
we going so so proposal okay great hey
EF Hutton what do you think about it
okay we're not going to be doing it
great the world is filled with e like
Henry Kissinger I don't know how much
you know about Henry Kissinger that gu's
an EF Hutton if there ever was one
there's a lot of those
guys that are the brains behind the
faces that we see and most of the times
the best EF Hutton no one ever finds out
who they
were no one ever finds out who those
guys are one of the other tensions that
I felt when learning about you and also
when watching your content you've spoken
about this specifically to do with Kobe
but I think it also probably plays a
role in almost everybody's life is this
tension between self-love and high
standards right it's the desire to
maximize everything you can and to not
leave more on the table than you need to
and also the ability to enjoy the moment
and to be able to actually take some
some pleasure in that and there was a
something that came up from a friend
that I wrote about this week so I wanted
to explain this to you he did a
psilocybin journey in uh Australia and a
question came to him and the question
was do people love you for who you are
or for what you do this is uncomfortable
to consider people loving us for who we
are feels more real genuine caring
empathetic and robust it feels like
we're less fickle and more difficult to
lose on the other hand people loving us
for what we do feels transactional and
transient the love that we receive
becomes contingent on what achievements
and successes we can offer in return and
the obvious fear is that if a point came
where we no longer had anything to offer
in return would our love be taken away
so here's an even more uncomfortable
question do you love you for who you are
or for what you
do this highlights our hypocrisy you see
we want the world to love us for who we
are a balanced caring view of our true
value independent of our accomplishments
meanwhile our own self-love is largely
determined mined by what we do if we
fall short even though we know we tried
our best we still castigate ourselves
for being insufficient unworthy
creatures so we want the world to show
up for us in a way that we are often not
prepared to show up for ourselves you
demand More Than This demand it of
yourself
powerful do you see that resonating this
tension in high performers desire for
more requirement for
self-love yes but for me there's a part
of that's also
honest because again the relationship
with between a man and a
prostitute what is that relationship
each side is getting something in return
the prostitute is getting what money
what's the man getting pleasure okay and
they walk away it's done it's a very
honest relationship right there's no
depth in that relationship it's straight
up it's honest done we move on
okay um
working at a
company say you work with a
company and he helps the YouTube channel
go to the next level doing all the work
behind closed doors all this stuff would
he do that job for free or would he do
it because you're offering something
back to them how many of my employees
would be with me if it was working for
free that nonprofit would be kind of
weird guys what we're doing is very
important but I need you to work for
free what do you mean are you going to
make money I am but I want you to work
for free it's kind of weird right there
needs to be an exchange again it's
honest exchange
okay um if I go above and beyond
everybody else and I work should I
deserve the right to get paid more yes
okay is it beneficial for me to work
with somebody like you of course why
because you're driven so should I hang
on to your cail because if I go with you
big things are going to happen in my
life absolutely is that a selfish
decision yes but it's also a wise
decision do you know that you know that
do they know that they know that do they
also know that you have options because
now you're at a point that a lot of
people would love to be working for you
of course they know that they're not
dummies right they know that okay but
you still choose to stay with them and
they still choose choose to stay with
you is there benefit of somebody hiring
your person that's helping with your
podcast and paying twice as you pay to
go with them there is if he chooses to
take that just for the money that's his
loss if you're doing your part he was
never in it for believing in you it was
only about the money part so the these
are all and the reason why this is so
interesting what what you're reading
about self-love and all these other
things is when you look at some of the
people that make it at the highest of
the highest of the highest level they
typically have been backstabbed so much
that in the back of their mind sometime
they're just waiting to see who's going
to backstab in next so so the desire to
have a straightup relation relationship
is no longer the same okay there's a
difference between you dating somebody
who falls in love with you when you're
making 22 bucks an hour working at balys
and she loves you and she stays with you
there's a difference between you getting
married when you're making $300,000 a
year and then there's a difference
between you making marry somebody when
you're worth half a billion dollars how
do you know the girl that marries you at
the end is worth you know is with you
because she loves you versus she loves
what you offered them right and is that
a sin yeah is she making a mistake you
know I think in an Ideal
World I am very comfortable knowing that
other people are also there in your life
to get what they can out of
you I'm very comfortable with that
because there's a chapter in the book
here where I talk about choosing running
mates and I put a clear criteria on how
to choose a running mate you know what
they bring to the table their level of
trust with you all these ways of scoring
people in your life to see hey is this a
person because the whole concept with
choosing your enemies wisely you also
need to choose your allies wisely so
somebody like you you need True
Believers in your life you can't have 50
True Believers that's just naive to
think that you can't have 10 True
Believers can you have two to five True
Believers yes how how valuable is that a
lot so no I uh you know the more and
more I moved up the more I realized
almost everybody like and I'm talking
99% of people listen to uh the radio
show wiifm what's in it for me and a
part in this book that we dissected your
question which is fascinating question
is in in the company I've been running a
sales organization for 20-some years and
when I started the insurance company in
on9 we grew it from 66 agents today we
have 50,000 agents we've licensed
Nationwide we have a few hundred
officers
Nationwide but
my idea of looking at who's got the
biggest upside to contribute to the
company is also changed it used to be
man that guy is so
selfish all that guy cares about money
man this guy's the nicest guy in the
world and then I realize the nicest guy
in the world who had no selfish desires
was happy making $5,000 a
month and so then I created a scoring
system what percentage of you is selfish
and selfless and what's the good balance
if you're 100% only to you and everybody
else zero well guess what you're still a
bigger net positive to society than the
person at the bottom that's what 0%
selfish and 100% selfless if a person is
100% selfless they probably don't eat
well they probably out of shape they're
probably not healthy they're probably
going to have to go to the hospital it's
going to cost you money in taxes they
probably smell because they don't take a
shower they spend their money on
everybody else so then you'll see the
profile good people to give you counsel
are around the 50/50 range you can
always trust them to give you counsel
drivers of a company
or somebody like you doing what they do
7030 is a good split okay 8020 is a
little bit problematic because 8020
sometimes will compromise to beat
everybody so you want the 657 so you're
asking a technical question and I've
just come to a conclusion that you know
both parties if they want to selfishly
be pleased if we can please each other
and one of us takes the lead and we're
getting Mutual love and benefits out of
the
relationship you're in a good situation
every once in a while you'll find
somebody that's going to be your writer
that they're going to say Chris dude no
matter what you do I'm with you till the
day you die and you think they're
telling the
truth year goes by they're still there
even more five years go by they got
married like well when he get when he
gets married and ask it's going to
change still there 10 years later he
still there you're like this guy's
really a True Believer wow but it's not
going to be that many people that's a
very short list of people Patrick bat
David ladies and gentlemen Patrick I
appreciate the hell out of you I
appreciate how much you pay attention
very detail oriented and I love that I
really really do uh thank you for today
man it's been a long time coming so
where should people go they want to keep
up to date with everything you're doing
oh I mean you can go to Amazon and
search choose your enemies wisely uh or
you can find our podcast pbd podcast or
value tainment we're all over the place
you'll find us thank you man but this
has been a Blas man talking to you I've
been watching it for a long time and
it's very obvious why you're climbing
the way you are I appreciate you any
time thank you thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Patrick you will love my three-hour
long episode with Alex hosy go on tap
it